Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. The Tudors transformed. monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、享受无广告收听、提前获得系列节目更新并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问therestishistory.com并加入俱乐部。网址是therestishistory.com。本期节目由Hive赞助播出。你知道，历史充满了变革。罗马人从共和国转变为帝国；都铎王朝将修道院改造成了乡间别墅。你知道吗？Hive也经历了自己的变革。人们熟知Hive是因为智能恒温器，但现在它们已经发展成为更伟大的产品。太阳能电池板可以
help you to power your home with clean energy. Heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air. EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep. All managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes. from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps.
帮助您用清洁能源为家提供动力；热泵从空气中汲取热量；电动汽车充电器让您在睡眠时为汽车充电。所有这些都可以通过一个应用程序进行管理。这一切都是为了赋予人们改造家园的力量：从浪费到高效，从依赖到控制，从消耗到贡献。因此，历史上下一个伟大的变革可能不会发生在议会或宫殿里，而是可能发生在你的家中。一场没有断头台的无声革命。Hive，了解你的力量。访问hivehome.com了解更多详情。需视实地勘测和适用情况而定。Hive应用程序与指定的的热泵兼容。
For the moment, let them enjoy a calm sea, a fresh breeze and each other. The girl is pretty, and I was always sentimental. But for Jason, there are other adventures. I have not finished with Jason. Let us continue the game another day. So that, as everybody will know, was Zeus, the king of the gods. He is staring down from Mount Olympus at the Greek hero Jason. And Jason's had an extraordinary time. He sailed all the way from Greece to the distant land of Caucasus,
暂时让它们享受平静的海面、清凉的微风和彼此的陪伴吧。这姑娘长得挺俊，而我一向多愁善感。不过对于伊阿宋（Jason），还有别的冒险等着他。我和伊阿宋的故事还没完呢。让我们改天再继续这场游戏吧。那么，正如大家所知，那是宙斯，众神之王。他正从奥林匹斯山上俯视着希腊英雄伊阿宋。伊阿宋经历了一段非凡的旅程。他一路从希腊航行到遥远的卡加萨斯（Caucasus）土地，
at the other side of the Black Sea, possibly in present-day Georgia. And he's gone there in his ship, the Argo, with the Argonauts. He has captured the fleece of a golden ram from Aetis, the king of Colchis. He has won the heart of Aetis's daughter, who is called Medea, who is a bit of a witch, literally, but very beautiful. And she has helped Jason to win the golden fleece, and it's Medea, of whom Zeus says, the girl is pretty. Poor from Zeus. And these are the very last lines of the film Jason the Argonauts, which came out in 1963, and it starred Todd Armstrong as Jason, very wooden, and Pussy Galore herself, Honour Blackman,
位于黑海的另一侧，可能在今天的格鲁吉亚。他乘着他的船“阿尔戈号”（Argo）和阿尔戈英雄们一起到了那里。他从科尔基斯的国王埃厄忒斯（Aetes）那里夺取了金羊毛。他赢得了埃厄忒斯女儿的心，她叫美狄亚（Medea），有点像个女巫，字面意义上的女巫，但非常漂亮。她帮助伊阿宋赢得了金羊毛，而宙斯正是对美狄亚说：“这姑娘长得挺俊。”真不愧是宙斯。而这正是1963年上映的电影《阿尔戈英雄》（Jason and the Argonauts）的最后几句台词，由托德·阿姆斯特朗（Todd Armstrong）饰演伊阿宋，表情非常僵硬，还有大名鼎鼎的“朋西·加洛尔”（Pussy Galore）本人——奥纳·布莱克曼（Honour Blackman），
as Hera, the Queen of the Gods. Now, Tom, you think this is a brilliant film, don't you? I love it. I think it's a bit rubbish, but you think it's brilliant. So before we come on to the question of whether it's good or bad, there is a friend of the show who thinks it's It's not just good, but the best film ever made. Wow. Just to talk about Heera on a black man.
饰演赫拉，众神之后。好了，汤姆，你觉得这是一部神作，对吧？我太喜欢了。我觉得有点烂，但你觉得它太棒了。所以在我们讨论它是好是坏之前，节目有一位老朋友认为它不仅好，而且是有史以来拍得最好的电影。哇。就为了谈谈奥纳·布莱克曼饰演的赫拉。
And she plays a key role in the film because she actually has a bit of a crush on Jason. And so she's always looking out for him throughout her adventures. And in the film, she's a kind of figurehead on the Argo with great long lashes, which she flutters at Jason. Oh, lovely. Yeah. Every so often. So incredible special effects. And Wenzu says, let us continue the game another day, he says,
她在电影中扮演了关键角色，因为她实际上对伊阿宋有点暗恋。所以她在他的整个冒险过程中一直在照顾他。在电影中，她是“阿尔戈号”上的某种船头雕像，有着长长的睫毛，她对伊阿宋眨着眼睛。哦，太可爱了。是的。每隔一段时间。所以特效太不可思议了。当宙斯说“让我们改天再继续这场游戏吧”，他说这话时，
that looking at Hera because they've basically been playing chess with the lives of the Argonauts moving it around the chess board on Mount Olympus. It's obvious from that that the script writers were hoping that they would get a sequel. But the problem is that moviegoers agreed with you and thought it was rubbish. Yeah. So the film completely bombed and so they never got the chance to do Jason the Argonauts part two. But Dominic, it is now widely recognized as a classic. I think that's very strong, Tom, widely recognized as a classic. And the A person who thinks it's brilliant is a friend of the show, Tom Hanks, who in 1992 compared it to Casablanca and Citizen Kane and then said, it's better than them.
正看着赫拉，因为他们基本上一直在用奥林匹斯山上的棋盘下棋，用阿尔戈英雄们的生命作为棋子在棋盘上移动。从这一点很明显可以看出，编剧们是希望拍续集的。但问题是，影迷们和你想的一样，觉得这片子烂透了。是的。所以这部电影彻底扑街了，他们再也没有机会拍《阿尔戈英雄第二集》了。但多米尼克，现在它被广泛公认为一部经典。我觉得这个评价太高了，汤姆，说是广泛公认的经典。而那个认为它很棒的人，是节目的老朋友汤姆·汉克斯（Tom Hanks），他在1992年把它比作《卡萨布兰卡》和《公民凯恩》，然后说：‘它比它们还要好。’
It is the greatest film ever made. It hasn't struck you that Tom Hanks might have been being ironic? I don't think so. No. I don't think so because he was doing it just before the Oscars. Part of a special Lifetime Achievement Award that was being given to Ray Harry Housen. oh yeah who was the most you know the most famous special effects guru in the whole of Hollywood history so if you ever seen a film where monsters move in a slightly staccato matter
这是有史以来最伟大的电影。你难道没觉得汤姆·汉克斯当时可能是在说反话吗？我不这么觉得。不。我不觉得，因为他是在奥斯卡颁奖典礼前夕这么说的。这是雷·哈里豪森（Ray Harryhausen）获得的终身成就奖特别奖的一部分，
the likelihood is that ray harryhausen was behind that and his work on jason and the argonauts is widely seen now as the absolute acme of pre-cggy special effects and it's amazing for a film that was made in 1963 so special effects highlights in jason and the argonauts for those who haven't seen it, include Talos, who's a giant bronze warrior who comes to life and picks up the Argo and drops it into the sea. There are harpies who are two winged monsters who keep sweeping down and stealing food from a poor guy called Phineas, who has offended the gods. He's a blind seer, a lot of blind seers in Greek myth. He's Patrick Troughton. He's the second doctor from Doctor Who. Very underrated doctor, actually. He is. Yeah. Yes. So I thought you'd enjoy it. I mean,
哦，是的，他是整个好莱坞历史上最著名的特效大师。所以如果你看过任何一部怪物以略显断续的方式移动的电影，
He's got Honour Blackman. It's got Patrick Trouton. It's got amazing things. It's ticking all my boxes. Yeah. It's just a bad film. I'll tell you, who else it's got. Nigel Green, who was the sergeant in Zulu.
很可能是雷·哈里豪森在幕后操刀，他对《阿尔戈英雄》的工作现在被广泛视为前CGI时代特效的绝对巅峰之作，对于一部1963年制作的电影来说，这太惊人了。所以，《阿尔戈英雄》中的特效亮点，对于没看过的人来说，包括塔罗斯（Talos），一个巨大的青铜战士，它活了过来，拿起“阿尔戈号”并把它扔进海里。还有哈耳庇厄（Harpies），它们是两个带翅膀的怪物，不断俯冲下来，从一个叫菲纽斯（Phineus）的可怜家伙那里偷食物，这个家伙得罪了神。他是一个盲人先知，希腊神话里有很多盲人先知。他是帕特里克·特罗顿（Patrick Troughton）。他是《神秘博士》（Doctor Who）中的第二任博士。其实是一位被严重低估的博士。他的确是。是的。对。所以我想你会喜欢它的。我的意思是，
Oh, yes. Who played Heracles. Yes. And most amusingly of all, Argus, who's the guy who builds the Argo and is the captain. He's played by the guy who in a night to remember the great film about Titanic played Captain Smith. Well, he's a great act. honest, you know, if you've got to sail a ship from Greece to Colchis, Captain Smith is the last person you'd walk.
它有奥纳·布莱克曼。它有帕特里克·特罗顿。它有惊人的东西。它满足了我所有的期待。是的。这只是一部烂片。我告诉你，它还有谁。奈杰尔·格林（Nigel Green），曾在《祖鲁战争》（Zulu）中饰演中士。
No, more slander of Captain Smith. Captain Smith completed many, many, many voyages before that unfortunate incident. He was a very reliable captain, and I just want to make it absolutely clear. Once again, I would happily sail with Captain Smith at any date you care to mention, except probably that night in 1912. Would you trust Captain Smith to get the Argo through the clashing rocks? Well, he clearly did. did. So I'll be steering wood.
哦，是的。他饰演了赫拉克勒斯（Heracles）。是的。最搞笑的是阿耳戈斯（Argus），也就是建造“阿尔戈号”并担任船长的那个家伙。扮演他的人，在关于泰坦尼克号的伟大电影《难忘的一夜》（A Night to Remember）中扮演了史密斯船长（Captain Smith）。好吧，他是个伟大的演员。说真的，如果你得开着一艘船从希腊去科尔基斯，史密斯船长绝对是最后一个你会考虑的人。
Yeah, right. Clashing rocks also appear in Jason the Argonauts. And the most famous special effects in Jason and the Argonauts is skeletons that rise up out of the earth after King Aetis, who's furious because Jason's stolen the golden fleece. He sews the teeth of a monster
不，别再诽谤史密斯船长了。史密斯船长在那次不幸事件之前完成了许多许多次航行。他是一个非常可靠的船长，我只想明确这一点。再说一次，只要你愿意，我随时乐意与史密斯船长一起航行，除了1912年的那个晚上可能不行。你会相信史密斯船长能带着“阿尔戈号”穿过撞击岩（clashing rocks）吗？嗯，他显然做到了。所以我会掌舵的。
that Jason has slown. And these skeletons fight with Jason and two of his friends, kills two of the friends, and Jason jumps into the sea. I mean, if you haven't seen it, it's on YouTube. It's absolutely brilliant. That idea of sewing the dragon's teeth may sound familiar because people may remember that Cadmus, the Prince of Tyre, who went searching for Europa, who dressed up as a manad in the
是的，没错。撞击岩也出现在《阿尔戈英雄》中。而《阿尔戈英雄》中最著名的特效是骷髅，它们在埃厄忒斯国王之后从大宗里复活，埃厄忒斯因为伊阿宋偷了金羊毛而愤怒。他播种了一个怪物的牙齿，
back eye, you know, the founder of Thebes, he had also sewn a monster's teeth from which armed warriors had sprouted. And it's true that they weren't skeletons and that Cadmus, rather than fight them, had picked up a rock and thrown it into the middle of them and they'd all kind of killed each other. But it's clearly the same basic idea. And so people may be wondering, well, what's this story that was Academus in Thebes? What's it doing in Jason and the Argonauts? Isn't this just a classic example of Hollywood taking bits and pieces from different myths and stitching it all together and making a complete kind of Frankenstein's monster out of the whole thing?
那个怪物被伊阿宋杀死了。这些骷髅与伊阿宋和他的两个朋友战斗，杀死了两个朋友，伊阿宋跳进了海里。我的意思是，如果你没看过，它在YouTube上。真的太棒了。播种龙牙这个主意听起来可能很耳熟，因为人们可能还记得提尔王子卡德摩斯（Cadmus），他去寻找打扮成酒神女祭司的欧罗巴（Europa），
But Dominic. Yeah, there's always a but. There is a but. Jason and the Argonauts, the film, is actually a very, very faithful adaptation of an epic called, the Argonautica, which was written sometime around 250 BC by a Greek poet called Apollonius of Rhodes. And this is the big source, isn't it, for the stories of the golden place? Now, one interesting thing about this which might have occurred to people listening is 250 BC
在《酒神的狂女》（The Bacchae）里，你知道的，底比斯的创立者，他也曾播种过一个怪物的牙齿，武装战士从里面破土而出。确实，它们不是骷髅，而且卡德摩斯没有跟它们战斗，而是捡起一块石头扔到它们中间，然后它们就自相残杀了。但这显然是同一个基本概念。所以人们可能会想，好吧，这是底比斯卡德摩斯的故事，它怎么会出现在《阿尔戈英雄》里？这不就是好莱坞从不同神话中东拼西凑、把它们缝合在一起，用整个故事拼出一个弗兰肯斯坦式的怪物吗？
is very late. So we are now well into the Hellenistic era, aren't we? So the era following the death of Alexander the Great, and we'll come back to that later in the show. But just take us through the Argonautica, because a lot of the elements, from the film are in the poem, right? Yeah, so Talos, the giant bronze man, you know who picks up the ship, the harpies, the clashing rocks, the spartoy, the sown men, they're all in the Argonautica.
但是多米尼克。是的，总有个但是。确实有个但是。电影《阿尔戈英雄》实际上是对一部名为《阿尔戈英雄纪》（Argonautica）的史诗非常非常忠实的改编，这部史诗是由一位名叫罗德岛的阿波罗尼奥斯（Apollonius of Rhodes）的希腊诗人大约在公元前250年左右写成的。这就是金羊毛故事的主要来源，对吧？现在，关于这一点的一个有趣的事情，听众可能会想到的就是公元前250年
So in Apollonius's poem, it's not Aetis who sows the dragon's teeth, it's Jason. And Jason is, as he does it, is drawing a plow that is being pulled by fire-breathing bulls. And the reason for this is that it's been set as a challenge by, Aetis who doesn't want to give him the golden fleece. And so basically Aetis has said, if you draw this plough with the fire breathing bulls and you sew the dragon's teeth and you lift it all the tail, then I will give you the golden fleece. And Jason gets away with it because Medea, who is the daughter of Aetis, priestess of Hecate, the kind of the goddess of magic and witchcraft and so on, has fallen in love with him. And she gives Jason a magic ointment,
时间非常晚。所以我们现在已经进入了希腊化时代，对吧？也就是亚历山大大帝死后的时代，我们稍后会在节目中回到这一点。不过，请带我们了解一下《阿尔戈英雄纪》，因为电影中的很多元素都在这首诗里，对吧？是的，所以塔罗斯，那个巨大的青铜人，你知道的，拿起船的那个，哈耳庇厄，撞击岩，斯巴托伊（Spartoy），播种出来的战士，都在《阿尔戈英雄纪》里。
so a sports anguant which he smears all over himself and it's fire resistant so he can cope with the fire breathing bulls it has a kind of incredible cocaine style effect on his self-confidence because Jason in the epic is actually he's a bit of a wuss
所以在阿波罗尼奥斯的诗中，播种龙牙的不是埃厄忒斯，而是伊阿宋。伊阿宋在这样做的时候，拉着一架由喷火公牛拉着的犁。这样做的原因是因为这是埃厄忒斯设下的挑战，他不想把金羊毛给他。所以基本上埃厄忒斯说，如果你能用喷火公牛拉这架犁，播种龙牙，并把它们全部解决掉，那么我就把金羊毛给你。伊阿宋侥幸过关，因为埃厄忒斯的女儿美狄亚，也就是赫卡忒（Hecate，魔法与巫术女神等）的女祭司，已经爱上了他。她给了伊阿宋一瓶魔法药膏，
so he needs a bit of a top-up he gets away with it he manages to draw the plow fire-breathing bulls they incinerate him and all of that and she's also the one who advises him to pull Cadmus's trick by throwing a stone into the middle of the sewn men.
一种运动软膏，他把它涂遍全身，它具有防火功能，所以他能够应付喷火公牛；它对他的自信心有一种不可思议的可卡因式的提振效果，因为史诗中的伊阿宋其实有点像个懦夫，
So the story of Jason plowing the field with the fire-breathing bulls, that's a very old one. The idea that the dragon's teeth then sprout up, this is Apollonius' invention. He explains it by saying that Athena, after Cadmus had killed the dragon, took its teeth and divided them up.
所以他需要一点状态加持。他成功过关了，他设法用喷火公牛拉了犁，公牛把火喷向他等等，而她也是建议他效仿卡德摩斯把石头扔进播种出的战士中间的人。
Oh, nice. The Cadmus and half got given to 80s. So a bit of kind of retrospective continuity there. Yes, yes. And you can see that there is something, I think, quite Hollywood about this. Apollonius basically, I mean, you could imagine him writing for movie franchises or whatever. The Argonautica is basically the model for all the adventures of Greek heroes that you get in children's books.
所以伊阿宋用喷火公牛犁地的故事是一个非常古老的故事。龙牙随后破土而出的想法，则是阿波罗尼奥斯的发明。他解释说，雅典娜在卡德摩斯杀死巨龙后，拿走了它的牙齿并把它们分开了。
Tales of Daring Doe, fights with monsters, all of that. It's not, as our previous episodes have been about, it's not about exploring the nature of the gods, plumbing the various dimensions of Dionysus or any of that. He's very, very concerned to write something that people will find page turning and exciting, interesting. And it works. I mean, it is a kind of thrilling story to read. But it's not just a thrilling story, is it? Because Apollonius, so Apollonius is a great poet, but he's also a scholar who knows loads about Greek myth. So actually, the comparison might be with a figure like J.R. Toggi, who's taking established myths and weaving them into, you know, throwing loads of elements in and creating a quest narrative that turns out to be a massive blockbuster. No?
哦，太妙了。卡德摩斯拿了一半，另一半给了埃厄忒斯。所以这有点像某种回溯性的连续性设定。是的，是的。你可以看到这里面确实有某种非常“好莱坞”的东西。阿波罗尼奥斯基本上，我的意思是，你可以想象他为电影系列之类写剧本。《阿尔戈英雄纪》基本上就是儿童读物中所有希腊英雄冒险故事的模板。
I think he's more, I'm surprised you didn't bring it up. I think he's more like a scriptwriter for a film in the Star Wars franchise. I only did that because I know you hate, you hate Star Wars. No, I'm happy to have Star Wars introduced because I think it's quite a good parallel. Okay. You know, with Star Wars, you have a kind of pre-existing universe where there are certain characters and certain plot lines, but you can kind of mess around with it, you can introduce new characters, you can take elements from one film and put it into another. And you can do that with kind of super, He is much more like a scriptwriter for a Marvel film than he is a Greek tragedian. So he's basically taking elements from the comic books that people, you know, have grown up with and they know and love and reworking them and throwing new things in and all of that stuff, right? Well, so think of Star Wars. You had those famously terrible prequels, didn't you? I am the Princess of Nabu and I have come to negotiate a tariff reduction. I mean, unbelievably boring. But it's a prequel to the famous, you know, that kind of of iconic Star Wars. Apollonius is doing something very similar because basically he's writing
各种惊险刺激的事迹、与怪物的战斗，全都在里面。它不像我们之前的节目那样，不是关于探索诸神的本质，深入探讨狄奥尼索斯（Dionysus）的各个维度之类的内容。他非常非常关心的是写出人们会觉得引人入胜、激动人心、有趣的东西。而且它确实奏效了。我的意思是，这是一个读起来非常惊心动魄的故事。但这不仅仅是一个惊心动魄的故事，对吧？因为阿波罗尼奥斯，阿波罗尼奥斯不仅是一位伟大的诗人，也是一位对希腊神话了如指掌的学者。所以实际上，这种对比可能类似于J.R.R.托尔金（J.R.R. Tolkien）这样的人物，他吸收既定的神话并将它们编织成——你知道的，融入大量元素，创造出一个最终成为巨大卖座大片的寻宝叙事。难道不是吗？
a prequel to the most famous of all Greek epics, which are homers. We see Achilles, who's going to be the hero of the Iliad as a little baby in the Argonautica. Oh my God, Anakin Skywalker. Dar Fader as a little boy. It's that kind of thing. This is the phantom menace of Greek mythology. That is the most damning thing you could possibly say about it. It's much better than that. When the Argonauts, they've got the Golden Fleece and they're sailing away from Colchis, and they take a mad route to get back to Greece along the Danube and the Rhone and end up in the Western Mediterranean. Yeah, don't go along the Rhone. That's bonkers.
我觉得他更像——我很惊讶你没有提这个。我觉得他更像《星球大战》系列的电影编剧。我这么做只是因为我知道你讨厌，你讨厌《星球大战》。不，我很高兴引入《星球大战》，因为我觉得这是一个很好的平行对比。好吧。你知道，在《星球大战》中，你有一个预先存在的宇宙，里面有某些角色和某些情节线，但你可以随意摆弄它，你可以引入新角色，你可以从一部电影中获取元素放到另一部电影中。你可以用这种超级……他更像漫威电影的编剧，而不是希腊悲剧作家。所以他基本上是从人们从小到大熟悉并喜爱的漫画书中提取元素，并对它们进行重新加工，抛出新的东西，诸如此类，对吧？好吧，想想《星球大战》。你经历过那些出了名的糟糕前传，对吧？我是纳布（Nabu）的女王，我来这里是为了谈判关税减免。我的意思是，无聊得难以置信。但它是著名的、标志性的《星球大战》的前传。阿波罗尼奥斯做的非常类似，因为基本上他在写
By tradition is where Odysseus sailed. And so this gives Apollonius the chance to have the Argonauts meet all kinds of characters and monsters that Odysseus will go on to meet. They pass the sirens, for instance, and Odysseus gets tied to the mast so he can hear the sirens. But when the Argonauts go by, they've got Orpheus, who is the great musician who's ever lived and he plays the liar and he out sings the sirens. And also you meet Circe who in the Odyssey turns Odysseus' men into pigs and then Odysseus kind of hangs out with him. And she turns out to be Medea's aunt. So it's like, a bit like Darth Vader turning out
所有希腊史诗中最著名的——荷马史诗的前传。我们在《阿尔戈英雄纪》中看到了将成为《伊利亚特》英雄的阿喀涅（Achilles）还是个小婴儿。哦天哪，阿纳金·天行者（Anakin Skywalker）。达斯·维达（Dar Fader）还是个小男孩。就是那种感觉。这是希腊神话中的《幽灵的威胁》（The Phantom Menace）。这是你能对它做出的最具毁灭性的评价。它比那好得多。当阿尔戈英雄们拿到金羊毛，驶离科尔基斯时，他们走了条疯狂的路线沿着多瑙河和罗讷河返回希腊，最后来到了西地中海。是的，千万别走罗讷河。那太疯狂了。
to be Luke's father. I'm impressed with my incredible. Amazing knowledge of Star Wars knowledge. Yeah, incredible. And so I think part of the fun of reading the Argonautica, if you know, anything about Greek myths. Seeing the familiar elements. Yeah. Yeah. It's like, oh, there's Jabba the Hut. And the Ewoks are back and his C3PO making his inevitable appearance.
按照传统，那是奥德修斯（Odysseus）航行的地方。这给了阿波罗尼奥斯一个机会，让阿尔戈英雄们遇到各种各样的角色和怪物，奥德修斯后来也会遇到这些角色和怪物。例如，他们经过了塞壬（sirens），奥德修斯被绑在桅杆上，这样他就能听到塞壬的歌声。但当阿尔戈英雄们路过时，他们有俄耳甫斯（Orpheus），他是活着的最伟大的音乐家，他弹奏里拉琴，他的歌声盖过了塞壬。还有，你遇到了喀耳介（Circe），她在《奥德赛》中把奥德修斯的船员变成了猪，然后奥德修斯和她混在一起。结果她成了美狄亚的姑妈。所以这有点像达斯·维达
You know, that's basically what it is. But having said that, for that reason, I think, just as people are kind of a bit sniffy, perhaps about Star Wars prequels, people were sniffy about the Argonautica as well. The charge that Apollonius was a scavenger and a plagiarist was one that followed him throughout his career. Traditionally, it is said that. And I knew that your hackles always arise when it is said that. Yeah. So it didn't. Yeah. But let's say for now that this is genuinely happened. He had as his critic the most admired and celebrated poet of the age who was a guy called Callimachus. Right. And Apollonius is writing, you know, an epic. It's full of monsters and so on.
成了卢克的父亲。我对自己的惊人知识量感到印象深刻。惊人的《星球大战》知识。是的，太惊人了。所以我觉得阅读《阿尔戈英雄纪》的乐趣之一，如果你对希腊神话有所了解的话，就是看到熟悉的元素。是的。是的。这就像是，哦，那是贾巴（Jabba the Hut）。伊沃克人（Ewoks）又回来了，还有C-3PO不可避免地登场。
Calimachus is writing very delicate, recondite poems. So if Apollonius is a scriptwriter for a Star Wars prequel, Colimachus is more like T.S. Eliot or Emily Dickinson. Or if he's working in cinema, he's making little art house face. 10 minutes long. Yes. And the reason for this is very self-conscious, because we are no longer living in an age of epic. And that trying to be Homer is mad, you know, we can never do it.
你知道，基本上就是这样。但话虽如此，正因为如此，我认为，正如人们对《星球大战》前传有点挑剔一样，人们对《阿尔戈英雄纪》也很挑剔。阿波罗尼奥斯是个拾荒者和抄袭者的指控伴随着他的一生。传统上人们都这么说。我知道每当这么说的时候，你总是会炸毛。是的，确实如此。所以它没有。好吧，但我们先假设这真的发生了。他的批评者是那个时代最受崇拜和赞誉的诗人，一个叫卡利马科斯（Callimachus）的家伙。没错。而阿波罗尼奥斯写的是（你知道的）一部史诗。里面充满了怪物等等。
the circumstances that were germane in Homer's age have completely vanished. You cannot help if you're going to try and write a Homeric epic, it will be pastiche, it will be kind of bombastic, it'll be kind of meretricious trash. Callimachus' nickname for Apollonius seems to have been the ibis, and this is a bird that could be seen everywhere in Egypt, very common. And it's always fascinated Greek writers for reasons that Peter Green, in his tremendous book on the Hellenistic period, from Alexander to Actium. I chose that as one of my favorite history books from Alexander to Actium.
卡利马科斯写的是非常精致、深奥的诗歌。所以如果阿波罗尼奥斯是《星球大战》前传的编剧，卡利马科斯更像是T.S.艾略特（T.S. Eliot）或艾米莉·狄金森（Emily Dickinson）。或者如果他在电影界工作，他是在拍那种只有10分钟长的小众文艺片。是的。而这样做的原因是非常自觉的，因为我们不再生活在一个史诗的时代，试图成为荷马简直是疯了，你知道的，我们永远做不到这一点，
It's like 6,000 pages long. Peter Green lived to the age of 200, didn't he? We're still writing books like when other people have been long dead. Brilliant historian. And very, very entertainingly written. So he explains why the ibis fascinated Greek writers. So this is Peter Green. The ibis was a foul feeder of gluttonous and indiscriminate veracity,
就像有6000页长。彼得·格林活到了200岁，不是吗？当其他人都已经作古很久了，我们还在写这样的书。杰出的历史学家。而且文笔非常非常生动有趣。所以他解释了为什么朱鹭会迷住希腊作家。所以这就是彼得·格林。朱鹭是一种贪婪且毫无选择、食量惊人的腐食动物，
scavenging any kind of filth or carrion. It was also popularly believed to offset its diet by giving itself water enemers and colonic irrigation per annum with its own beak. Besides copulating orally, nesting in date palms to avoid cats and having a gut over 40 yards long
靠搜寻各种污秽物或腐肉为生。人们还普遍认为，它会用自己的喙每年给自己进行水洗灌肠和结肠水疗来抵消这种饮食。除了口对口交配、在枣椰树上筑巢以躲避猫之外，它还有一条四十多码长的肠道，
and he then goes on to quote the geographer Strabo, who was writing in the reign of Augustus, omnivorous and unclean, the ibis is only with difficulty kept away from things that are clean themselves and alien to all defilement. So in other words, if we're to trust the tradition that Colimachus hated Apollonius, by comparing Apollonius to an ibis, he's essentially attacking
接着他引用了在奥古斯都统治时期写作的地理学家斯特拉波的话：杂食且不洁，朱鹭很难让人不把它和干净的事物联系在一起，也与所有污秽格格不入。换句话说，如果我们相信卡利马科斯讨厌阿波罗尼乌斯的传统，那么通过将阿波罗尼乌斯比作朱鹭，他本质上是在攻击
the Argonautica not just as a kind of, you know, a mess of scavenged bits of trash, but for poisoning the ancient pure springs of myth. And again, I think that is very like a kind of highbrow Critic of a Hollywood blockbuster. It's a Guardian film writer saying there are too many Marvel films and people should be watching more Ingmar Bergman. Exactly. That's essentially what he's saying. And I think, you know, on one level,
《阿尔戈英雄纪》不仅是一堆搜集来的垃圾碎片的混合物，而且还污染了古老纯净的神话之源。再说一次，我觉得这非常像好莱坞大片的某种高贵冷艳的影评人。就像《卫报》的电影撰稿人说漫威电影太多了，人们应该多看看英格玛·伯格曼。完全正确。这基本上就是他想表达的。而且我认为，从某种程度上讲，
you can see where Callimachus is coming from because the story of the Argonauts, I mean, it does draw on the foundational springs of Greek myth. Homer doesn't mention Medea, but he does specify that Circe was sister to Aetis. So, in fact, it wasn't Apollonius' invention that Medea was Ursi's niece. And equally, he doesn't mention the golden fleece, but he does mention Jason and specifically the clashing rocks.
你能理解卡利马科斯的想法，因为阿尔戈英雄的故事，我的意思是，它确实汲取了希腊神话的根本源泉。荷马没有提到美狄亚，但他确实明确指出瑟瑟是埃厄忒斯的姐姐。所以，事实上，美狄亚是瑟瑟的侄女并不是阿波罗尼乌斯的创造。同样，他没有提到金羊毛，但他确实提到了伊阿宋，尤其是撞击石。
So in the Odyssey, when Circe is warning Odysseus about the clashing rocks and says, you know, avoid them at all cost. Circe tells him that the Argo is the only ship that had ever passed through them. So to quote the Odyssey, the swells would have hurled her too against those gigantic rocks, had Hera not sent her on through, since Jason was dear to her. So pussy galore stepping in to save Jason. The rest of Apollonius' epic is culled from kind of various poets. So Hesiod is there. There's another poet from Thebes called Pinder,
所以在《奥德赛》中，当瑟瑟警告奥德修斯关于撞击石的事，并说，你知道的，无论如何要避开它们。瑟瑟告诉他，“阿尔戈”号是唯一一艘曾穿过它们的船。引述《奥德赛》的话就是：“如果赫拉没有因为珍视伊阿宋而送她一程，巨浪本会把她也撞向那些巨大的岩石。”所以是猫女出面拯救了伊阿宋。阿波罗尼乌斯的史诗其余部分都是从各种诗人的作品中挑选出来的。赫西俄德也在其中。底比斯还有另一位诗人叫品达，
who wrote in the 5th century BC, and in Athens, Euripides, a friend of the show, author of the Bacchi, who we talked about in the previous episode. So Pinder, we know from him that the story had begun with this absolutely kind of classic fairy tale, which revolves around a wicked stepmother who's out to get the two children of the king of Thessaly, who are called Frixus and Heli. And the brother and sister, Frixus and Heli, they escape on a flying ram with a golden fleece. And the ram takes off from Thessaly, flies over the Aegean, flies over the Hellespont. and there's a disaster because
他在公元前5世纪写作，在雅典还有欧里庇得斯，节目的老朋友，《巴克科斯女信徒》的作者，我们在上一集里聊过他。所以品达，我们从他那里得知，这个故事始于一个绝对经典的童话，围绕着一个恶毒的继母展开，她一心想除掉色萨利国王的两个孩子，他们叫弗里克苏斯和海莉。兄妹俩弗里克苏斯和海莉骑着一头背负金羊毛的飞羊逃跑了。这头公羊从色萨利起飞，飞越爱琴海，飞越赫勒斯庞特海峡，
Ellie hasn't got her seatbelt on and slips off and drowns in the stretch of water below. Yeah, hence the name. Hence the name, the Hellespon. But Frixus gets, he crosses the Black Sea, safely lands in Colchis and is given shelter by Aetis
然后灾难发生了，因为海莉没有系好安全带，从上面滑落，淹死在下方的一片水域中。是的，因此得名。因此得名，赫勒斯庞特。但弗里克苏斯成功了，他穿过黑海，安全降落在科尔基斯，并得到了埃厄忒斯的庇护。
and when the flying golden ram dies, the fleece brings prosperity to Aetis' kingdom and so he hangs it on a tree in a sacred grove where it is looked after by a dragon and the dragon the great serpent wraps its coils
当会飞的金羊毛公羊死后，羊毛给埃厄忒斯王国带来了繁荣，于是他把它挂在圣林里的一棵树上，由一条巨龙看守，巨龙，也就是那条巨蛇，盘绕着
around the tree. So this is all very familiar from the ladybird book of the Jason the Argonauts that I read when I was about five. And also I see that the rest of the details where Jason goes to get the fleece.
这棵树。所以这一切都和我大约五岁时读过的《小瓢虫读物》里的《伊阿宋与阿尔戈英雄》非常熟悉。而且我也看到伊阿宋去取羊毛的其他细节
They're also in the ladybird book and they're from Pindar too. Absolutely classic kind of Greek myth isn't it? His father, what was his going? Aeson, the king of, yeah, Iolcos. He's been kicked out by his uncle,
也都出现在小瓢虫读物里，它们也来自品达。绝对是典型的希腊神话，对吧？他的父亲，他叫什么来着？埃宋，嗯，伊奥尔科斯的国王。当伊阿宋还是个婴儿时，他被叔叔
Pilius, when Jason was a baby. And Jason, obviously, it's always the way he's been raised by a kind of wise old sage who is called Chiron and happens to be a centaur. Happens to be a centaur. But like, what's his name? The little gnome thing with a stupid voice. Oh, come on.
珀长给赶出来了。伊阿宋，很显然，一贯如此，是被一位名叫喀戎的聪明老智者抚养长大的，他碰巧是个半人马。碰巧是个半人马。但是，比如，他叫什么名字？那个声音很蠢的小侏儒东西。噢，得了吧。
Are you talking about Yoda? Yoda. Yoda. So, yeah, so Chiron is the Yoda. Ignorant to Star Wars are you, Tom Holland? Am I? That doesn't work, doesn't it. No.
你在说尤达吗？尤达。尤达。所以，是的，喀戎就是尤达。你对《星球大战》一无所知吗，汤姆·霍兰德？我吗？这行不通，对吧。不。
Luke doesn't speak in the saying Yoda's voice to Yoda. Come on. No, true. Okay. All right. So, meanwhile, back in Ayolcos, Pilius, there's obviously a prophecy. I mean, there's always a prophecy. And he's been worn to beware a man with one sandal.
卢克不会用尤达的声音对尤达说话。拜托。不，没错。好吧。好吧。那么，与此同时，回到伊奥尔科斯，珀长，显然有一个预言。我的意思是，总会有一个预言。他被警告要提防一个穿一只凉鞋的人。
And Jason, he's been instructed by Chiron past his A-levels. And so now it's time for him to set off to Iolkos. He's going along, and there's an old woman, there's a, swollen river. The old woman can't get across the river. So Jason gives her a piggyback. At the far side, the old woman transforms into Hera. And this is why Hera from this point on is Jason's a great patron. Bart Dominic, while he's been crossing the river, what do you think's happened to his footwear? Oh, his sandal has come off, hasn't it? Very famous. Yeah. Sandal has come off. Yes. So he turns up and Peleus sees this new arrival and realizes, oh my God, his trouble. So he comes up
而伊阿宋，他在喀戎的指导下通过了A-Level考试。所以现在是他出发前往伊奥尔科斯的时候了。他走着走着，遇到一个老妇人，有一条汹涌的河。老妇人过不了河。于是伊阿宋背着她过了河。到了对岸，老妇人变成了赫拉。这就是为什么从这一刻起，赫拉成了伊阿宋的强大保护者。巴特·多米尼克，当他过河的时候，你觉得他的鞋子怎么了？噢，他的凉鞋掉了，对吧？非常著名。是的。凉鞋掉了。是的。所以他出现了，珀长看到这个新来的人，意识到，噢天哪，他有麻烦了。所以他想出了
with a brilliant scheme, which is that he tells Jason, look, I will give you the throne, but first of all, I really think that you should go to Colchis and get the golden fleece. And people may be wondering, well, that's, you know, why would Jason do that? And Pius comes up with three unanswerable reasons. The first of these is that the ghost of frixus demands it, say the little boy. Yeah, don't argue with him. The second is an oracle has urged it. So you can't argue with that.
一个绝妙的计划，那就是他告诉伊阿宋：“听着，我会把王位交给你，但首先，我真的认为你应该去科尔基斯把金羊毛拿回来。”人们可能会想，嗯，那是，（心想）为什么伊阿宋要这么做？然后珀长提出了三个无法反驳的理由。其中第一个是弗里克苏斯的鬼魂要求这么做，那个小男孩说道。是的，别跟他争论。第二个是一个神谕极力主张这么做。所以你无法反驳这一点。
And the third is that just as the golden fleece has brought. peace and prosperity to Colchis. So if it gets stolen, then that peace and prosperity will be brought to Ayolcus. So unanswerable. Jason says, yeah, fine, whatever. And Peleus swears solemn vow that he will give Jason the throne if he comes back with the golden fleece. So to quote Pindar, so this was their agreement, and then they parted. And at once Jason ordered heralds everywhere to proclaim that a great voyage was to be made. And on the question of the voyage, so I remember Michael Wood did a TV series and Michael Wood has been on our show,
第三个是，正如金羊毛给科尔基斯带来了和平与繁荣。所以如果它被偷了，那么这种和平与繁荣就会带给伊奥尔科斯。所以无法反驳。伊阿宋说，好吧，随便，都可以。珀长庄严发誓，如果伊阿宋带着金羊毛回来，他就会把王位交给他。引用品达的话说，他们的协议就是这样，然后他们分开了。伊阿宋立刻命令各处的传令官宣告将进行一次伟大的航行。关于航行的问题，我记得迈克尔·伍德制作过一个电视系列节目，迈克尔·伍德曾上过我们的节目，
great TV historian, called In Search of Myths and Heroes and he went on this great sort of expedition to Georgia on the other side of the Black Sea and he was trying to sort of uncover the roots of the golden fleece myth and he was sort of arguing you know the roots lie in memories
他是位伟大的电视历史学家，节目名叫《寻找神话与英雄》，他去黑海对岸的格鲁吉亚进行了一次伟大的探寻，他试图揭开金羊毛神话的根源，并且他当时在争论，你知道的，这些根源在于
of Greek voyages out into the unknown across the Black Sea to a land that maybe had gold or some kinds of riches or who knows. There is a sense, isn't there, among historians and scholars, that the story of Jason the Golden Fleece does reflect a kind of historical reality,
希腊人穿越黑海向未知世界航行的记忆，去往一个可能拥有黄金或某种财富，或者谁知道呢的土地。在历史学家和学者中间，是不是有一种感觉，即伊阿宋与金羊毛的故事确实反映了一种历史现实，
which is, what would you call it, the Greek Age of Expiration? Yeah, a sense of... Colonization. Yeah, going out... I mean, Greeks obviously go to the Crimea, don't they? They do go across the Black Sea to the far side. When is that time period?
那就是，你把它叫作什么，希腊的探索时代？是的，一种……殖民的感觉。是的，走出去……我的意思是，希腊人显然去了克里米亚，对吧？他们确实穿过了黑海去往远方。那个时期是什么时候？
Because that must have been centuries distant by the time that people like... Well, certainly by the time Apollonius was writing. Eighth, seven centuries. Right. I mean, into the sixth century, and it's about a process of discovery, and they are venturing out into seas where you could well believe that you've come across clashing rocks or monsters or sirens or whatever. So whether you're going westwards or eastwards. So it's a bit like
因为到人们……的时候，那一定已经是几个世纪前的事了。嗯，当然是在阿波罗尼乌斯写作的时候。第八、七个世纪。没错。我的意思是，进入公元前6世纪，这是一个发现的过程，他们正在冒险进入那些你完全会相信自己会遇到撞击石、怪物、塞壬或诸如此类的海洋。所以无论你是向西还是向东航行。所以这有点像
the stories told by Vikings sailing off into the Atlantic or down the great rivers through Russia. But the problem, and this is, I think, why Callimachus has a point, is that by 250, BC. I mean, everybody knows what the Mediterranean and the Black Sea are like. No one could conceivably believe that there are monsters there. And so that, I think, is why Apollonius sends the Argonauts into kind of Middle Europa. Oh, the Rhone and whatnot. Yeah, because generally people don't know what's going on there. Right. So more opportunity for monsters. So the one character who everybody remembers Jason the Golden Fleece, the hypnotic figure of Medea, the beautiful sorceress who helps Jason, but then obviously things go very, very badly wrong for them as a
维京人扬帆驶入大西洋或顺着俄罗斯的大河而下的故事。但问题是，这也是为什么我认为卡利马科斯有道理的地方，那就是到了公元前250年。我的意思是，每个人都知道地中海和黑海是什么样的。没有人会相信那里有怪物。所以我想这就是为什么阿波罗尼乌斯把阿尔戈英雄派往欧洲中部的原因。哦，罗讷河之类的。是的，因为通常人们不知道那里发生了什么。没错。所以有更多机会遇到怪物。所以每个人都记得的关于伊阿宋和金羊毛的角色，美狄亚这个催眠般的人物，那个帮助伊阿宋的美丽女巫，但显然后来他们作为
couple. Where does she come from? Does she come from Pindar as well? Yes. So Pindar provides Apollonius with the outline of her story. And in Pindor's account, Madera is a very heroic figure, so as in the film, actually, and her aid is crucial to Jason's success. He wouldn't have been able to win the golden fleece without her. Aphrodite Pindar says, you know, casts a spell of love over her. And in Apollonius' version, it's ridiculous. Aphrodite gets Eros, her son, to shoot an arrow. And Eros is like the kind of most annoying. It's like scrappy do. He's like a kind of infuriating child friendly character. It's just terrible. Like Jar Jar Binks. Yes. He's the Jar Jajar Binks of Greek epic poetry. And Medea is,
一对伴侣，事情变得非常非常糟糕。她是从哪里来的？她也是从品达那里来的吗？是的。所以品达为阿波罗尼乌斯提供了她故事的大纲。在品达的叙述中，美狄亚是一个非常英雄化的角色，实际上就像电影里一样，她对伊阿宋的成功至关重要。没有她，他是赢不到金羊毛的。品达说，阿佛洛狄忒对她施下了爱情的咒语。而在阿波罗尼乌斯的版本中，这就很荒谬了。阿佛洛狄忒让她的儿子厄洛斯射出一支箭。而厄洛斯就像那种最烦人的。就像 scrappy doo（史酷比里的烦人小狗）。他就像那种惹人厌烦的、适合儿童的角色。这简直太糟糕了。就像贾贾·宾克斯。是的。他就是希腊史诗中的贾贾·宾克斯。而美狄亚，
she's got this arrow of love embedded in her heart. It leads her to basically portray her. father give Jason the magic ointment that enables him to, you know, harness the bulls and pep up his confidence. And also Medea helps him to kill the dragon that's been guarding the golden feast. She has another ointment, puts it in the dragon's eyes and the dragon falls asleep, and Jason then kills it. And on the long voyage back, she provides the Argonauts with magic and prophecy. That basically is the outline that Pinder gives Apollonius and Apollonius kind of sticks to it. There is another much more famous literary portrayal of Medea that Apollonius had inherited and had to negotiate.
她的心脏里插着这支爱情之箭。这导致她基本上背叛了她的父亲，把神奇的药膏给伊阿宋，使他能够，你知道的，驯服公牛并提振他的信心。而且美狄亚还帮他杀死了守护金羊毛的巨龙。她有另一种药膏，涂在巨龙的眼睛上，巨龙就睡着了，然后伊阿宋杀死了它。在返程的长途航行中，她为阿尔戈英雄提供魔法和预言。这基本上就是品达给阿波罗尼乌斯的大纲，而阿波罗尼乌斯基本上遵循了它。还有一个更著名的关于美狄亚的文学形象，是阿波罗尼乌斯继承并必须处理的。
And this comes from Euripides. Yeah, we know that Euripides loves a really dark play. And he loves a murderous woman. And in Euripides' play about Medea, she is portrayed in a very dark light. And she is guilty of assorted crime. So in the backstory, she, as the Argonauts escape, she's taken her brother with her in one account. As Iyte's fleet is closing in on the Argonauts,
这来自欧里庇得斯。是的，我们知道欧里庇得斯喜欢非常黑暗的戏剧。他喜欢一个杀人的女人。在欧里庇得斯的关于美狄亚的戏剧中，她被描绘成一种非常黑暗的形象。她犯有各种各样的罪行。所以在背景故事中，当阿尔戈英雄逃跑时，根据一种说法，她把她的哥哥带在身边。正当埃厄忒斯的舰队逼近阿尔戈英雄时，
she chops her brother up into two people. and throws it out into the sea. Such a weird and unsettling detail. So Aetis has to stop to pick up the bits. Or in another account, the brother is leading the pursuit and Medea kills him. When they get back to Thessaly, Pilias predictably does not hand over the throne. So Medea eliminates him. And she does it in a kind of brilliantly complicated way.
她把她的哥哥砍成两半，并扔进海里。多么诡异和令人不安的细节。所以埃厄忒斯不得不停下来捡这些碎块。或者在另一种说法中，哥哥带头追捕，而美狄亚杀了他。当他们回到色萨利时，珀长不出所料地没有交出王位。于是美狄亚除掉了他。她用了一种极其复杂的方式。
She gets Pilius's daughters. And she says, look, I have incredible powers of sorcery. Your father is very, very elderly. I can make him much younger. Look, and she bruise up a potion in a cauldron, and she gets an aged ram, and she slits the throat of the ram, and then she chops the ram up into little bits. This is obviously something the Medea's really into, is chopping up bodies. And she chucks all the portions of the ram into the cauldron. And there's kind of shimmering and a flash. And then a minute later, the ram pops out, and it's now a baby lamb, kind of had all its youth restored to it. And she says, if you do this to your father, then I'll be able to do the same. And so Peles's daughter's get their father, slit his throat, chop him into bits, chuck him into the cauldron, and nothing happens. And that's the end of Pileas.
她找到珀长的女儿们。她说：“看，我有不可思议的巫术法力。你们的父亲非常非常老了。我可以让他变得年轻得多。看，”她在一个大锅里熬制了一份药剂，她抓来一只老龄公羊，割断公羊的喉咙，然后把公羊切成小块。这显然是美狄亚非常热衷的事，就是切碎尸体。她把公羊的所有部分都扔进大锅里。然后有一阵闪烁和亮光。接着过了一会儿，公羊跳了出来，现在它成了一只小羔羊，恢复了所有的青春。她说：“如果你们对你们的父亲这样做，那么我也能对你们父亲做同样的事。”于是珀长的女儿们找到她们的父亲，割断他的喉咙，把他切成碎块，扔进大锅里，结果什么也没发生。珀长就这样结束了。
So Jason then can become king of Ioccus and Thessaly. And you'd think that he'd be very grateful to Medea. But by this point, Jason is thinking, you know, she's a bit of a nightmare. She's just, you know, endlessly chopping people up. And faithfully, in Euripides version, he dumps Medea for a princess called Glauque, who's the princess of Corinth. and so Medea doesn't take this lying down and she sends Glauque a poisoned dress and crown and Glauque puts it on and vanishes in a puff of smoke and Medea then goes off
所以伊阿宋随后可以成为伊奥尔科斯和色萨利的国王。你本以为他会对美狄亚非常感激。但到了这个时候，伊阿宋觉得，你知道的，她简直是个噩梦。她只是，你知道的，没完没了地把人切成块。忠实于欧里庇得斯的版本，他抛弃了美狄亚，和一个名叫格劳刻的公主在一起，她是科林斯的公主。所以美狄亚可不会逆来顺受，她给格劳刻送了一件带毒的裙子和王冠，格劳刻穿上后在一团烟雾中消失了，接着美狄亚去
kills the two sons that she's had by Jason thereby denying him any male heirs and flies off in a chariot drawn by dragons and goes to Athens she's a piece of work isn't she She's the Mary Lincoln of Greek mythology, Tom. So harsh. So hard. I hope the people on the Reddit enjoy that one. Continue. Basically, Euripides' influence is so strong.
杀死了她为伊阿宋生下的两个儿子，从而剥夺了他任何男性继承人，然后乘着一辆由巨龙拉着的战车飞走，去了雅典。她真是一个狠角色，不是吗？她就是希腊神话中的玛丽·林肯，汤姆。太苛刻了。太严厉了。我希望Reddit上的人会喜欢这个梗。继续。基本上，欧里庇得斯的影响力太强大了。
He's become such a kind of classic by this point, that this is now the canonical understanding of Medea. But it doesn't really suit Apollonius' purposes. I mean, it's too bloodstained, too murderous. And so essentially he kind of slightly whitewashes that out. I mean, that is so Hollywood. You know, oh, we want to take it out. It's like the, yeah, it's like the Adam West Batman.
他到这个时候已经成为了一个经典，以至于这现在成了对美狄亚的正统理解。但这并不太符合阿波罗尼乌斯的目的。我的意思是，它太血腥了，太嗜杀了。所以基本上他稍微把那部分美化淡化了。我的意思是，这太好莱坞了。你知道的，“哦，我们想把它拿掉。”就像，是的，就像亚当·韦斯特版的《蝙蝠侠》。
It's, you know, all the dark, light stuff. I'm just going to say it first before the listeners do. There's a lot of ludicrous parallels being made in this episode. I think it's not. But we lean into it. We love it. Euripides, Sophocles, the Great Tragedians, they have become classics. And they have put later poets in their shadow.
你知道的，所有的黑暗、轻松的东西。我先说出来，在听众说之前。这一集里做了很多荒谬的类比。我认为并非如此。但我们乐在其中。我们很喜欢。欧里庇得斯、索福克勒斯，这些伟大的悲剧作家，他们已经成为了经典。他们把后来的诗人笼罩在自己的阴影之下。
And Apollonius, you know, has this anxiety of influence. He's always conscious of it. And that is really Kalimachus' point is that you can't write something fresh about Medea because we have these, you know, the Euripides' portrait means that you're always going to be operating in its shadow. And the only thing that Apollonis can do basically is to ignore that, set it aside. And there's a kind of parallel, I think, in which the way that poets in, say, you know, 250 BC are in the shadow of a vanished greatness, literary greatness.
而阿波罗尼斯，你知道的，有一种影响的焦虑。他一直都意识到这一点。这正是卡利马库斯的核心观点：你无法写出关于美狄亚的全新作品，因为我们有了——你知道的，欧里庇得斯的塑造意味着你将永远活在它的阴影之下。阿波罗尼斯基本上能做的唯一一件事就是忽视这一点，把它放在一边。我认为，这与公元前250左右的诗人生活在一个已经消逝的伟大文学成就的阴影之下的情况有一种相似之处。
politically Athens is slightly similar because Athens now in 250 BC stands in the shadows of empires that are vastly greater than the empire that the Athenians had run in the 5th century and the independence of Athens and of all the other Greek city states has effectively been snuffed out and Dominic I mean you know you know by whom yeah no one loves this more than I do
在政治上，雅典也有点类似，因为公元前250年的雅典，正置身于庞大帝国的阴影之下，这些帝国远比雅典人在公元前5世纪所建立的帝国要宏大得多，雅典以及所有其他希腊城邦的独立实际上已经被掐灭了。多米尼克，我的意思是，你知道——你知道是谁干的，对吧？没有人比我更喜欢看这个了。
I love to see the Athenians get a kicking from Macedon so Philip of Macedon started it didn't he in 338 he smashed the Athenians and the Thebans and then four years later Alexander the Great one of the very top friends of the rest is history he'd gone off on his I think what we described as a gap here that got out of control conquering the Persian Empire going off to Afghanistan
我最喜欢看雅典人被马其顿人狠狠地教训一番了。所以马其顿的腓力开启了这一切，不是吗？公元前338年，他击溃了雅典人和底比斯人，然后四年后，亚历山大大帝——这位“余下历史俱乐部”的顶级好友之一——踏上了我所认为的那种失控的“间隔年”之旅，征服了波斯帝国，一路远征到阿富汗。
dressing up in his foreign clothing Exactly exactly taking proscenesis adopting Persian customs Goes off to Central Asia goes off to India and then he dies in 3-2-3 and his empire is carved up and it's always sort of said or it fragmented into these pitiful little success estates
穿着异国的服装。没错，没错，行叩拜礼（proskynesis），采纳波斯习俗。前往中亚，前往印度，然后在公元前323年去世，他的帝国被瓜分。人们总是说，或者说它分裂成了一堆可怜的小型继业者国家。
but actually those success of states are pretty powerful and rich empires the Sunucid Empire the Ptolemaic Empire and I guess the most glamorous certainly for me and it's the place when people say where would you go
但实际上，这些继业者国家是相当强大且富裕的帝国：塞琉古帝国、托勒密帝国，而我猜其中最具魅力的，对我而言绝对是亚历山大里亚。每当人们问起，如果你有一台时光机，你会去哪里——
if you had a time machine a classic Restis History Club question Alexandria it's Alexandria rather than Athens that is the real metropolis in this period isn't it the city of culture, of science. It's a mega city.
这是一个经典的“余下历史俱乐部”的问题——亚历山大里亚，比起雅典，亚历山大里亚才是这个时期真正的超级都市，不是吗？文化之城，科学之城。它是一座特大城市。
Yeah. Yeah. Obviously, it's founded by Alexander, named after him with Alexander's customary modesty. And the thing about Alexandria, as opposed to Athens or Thebes, with their kind of ancient stories about their beginnings and their ancient relations with the gods and heroes,
对，对。显然，它是亚历山大建立的，并以他的名字命名，带有亚历山大一贯的谦逊。关于亚历山大里亚，与那些拥有关于其起源的古老故事以及与神祇和英雄的古老关系的雅典或底比斯不同，
is that on the site of Alexandria, before Alexander arrived there, there had been nothing. There was only kind of marshes and sea birds. The St. Petersburg of North Africa. Yeah. No temple.
在于亚历山大到达之前，亚历山大里亚的这片土地上曾是一片空白。那里只有沼泽和海鸟。北非的圣彼得堡。是的。没有神庙。
no festivals and crucially no myths. And so then there's an obvious question. What do the ancient gods mean in a city where everyone is an immigrant? What relevance do these ancient Greek poems now have? And I think that that's what the argument between Climachus and Apollonius is all about. Neither of them come from Greece, old Greece. Climachus had moved there from Cyrene, which is a city in what's now Libya. And Apollonius himself, despite his name, Apollonius of Rhodes, seems actually to have been born in Alexandria. and he was called off-roads because he liked visiting there. Can Alexandria be a place?
没有节日，最关键的是，没有神话。于是，一个显而易见的问题随之产生：在一个每个人都是移民的城市里，古代的神祇意味着什么？这些古希腊诗歌现在还有什么关联？我认为，这正是卡利马库斯和阿波罗尼斯之间争论的核心所在。他们两人都不是来自希腊本土、旧希腊。卡利马库斯是从昔兰尼搬到那里的，那是一座位于现今利比亚境内的城市。而阿波罗尼斯本人，尽管他叫罗德岛的阿波罗尼斯，实际上似乎出生在亚历山大里亚，他被称为“罗德岛的”是因为他喜欢去那里访问。亚历山大里亚能成为一个地方吗？
What role does myth have in such a city? And I think that Callimachus' charge against Apollonius, therefore, is very clear and not unjustified, which is that if you're going to write an ancient epic and you are doing so as a citizen of a Parvenu megacity like Alexandria, then you can't help but be kind of vulgar and meretricious. And I suppose it's slightly, again, like, you know, high-bramble. British attitudes towards American films. Right, exactly. But it's also, interestingly, it mirrors the criticism that historians for a long time
神话在这样的城市里扮演什么角色？因此，我认为卡利马库斯对阿波罗尼斯的指控非常明确，也并非毫无根据：如果你要写一部古代史诗，而你的身份是像亚历山大里亚这样暴发户特大城市的公民，那么你就不免会显得有点庸俗和浮华。我想，这再次有点类似于，你知道的，英国人对美国电影的高雅与粗俗的态度。没错，完全如此。但有趣的是，这也反映了长期以来历史学家对希腊化时代所做出的批评，不是吗？
have actually made of the Hellenistic era, haven't they? Historians and critics, really since the 19th century, you've been holding up Greece, the classical age of Greece as the model, have then said, oh, and what came next was vulgar and meretricious and a bit of a pastiche? Yeah. And, I mean, that's the classic criticism of Hellenistic culture. But just to reiterate, I mean, that is the criticism that Callimachus is making, who is probably the greatest poet. He's anticipating it, yeah.
历史学家和评论家们，自19世纪以来，一直将希腊、希腊的古典时代奉为典范，然后说：“哦，接下来出现的一切都是庸俗、浮华且有点东施效颦的赝品？”是的。我的意思是，这就是对希腊化文化的经典批判。但重申一下，我的意思是，这就是卡利马库斯——可能最伟大的诗人——所提出的批判。他在提前预料到这一点，对吧？
Calimachus is looking back to Athens and to Homer as the true golden age of Greek literature. Yeah. And, you know, we do the same by and large. Yeah. That tends to be the assumption. You do. I actually love the Hellenistic era. I prefer to Pasco-Greece.
卡利马库斯回望雅典和荷马，将其视为希腊文学真正的黄金时代。是的。而且，你知道的，大体上我们也这样做。是的。这往往是默认的假设。你是这样的。我其实很喜欢希腊化时代。我比古典希腊更喜欢它。
I love the Hellenistic era too, but I can recognize. that there is a point to Kalimachus's criticism that it is slightly ursats. Because you don't like multiculturalism like I do, Tom. No, Dominic. There is an Erzatz quality to trying to write an epic about a corner of the world that
我也很喜欢希腊化时代，但我能承认卡利马库斯的批判是有道理的，它确实有点山寨味。因为你不像我一样喜欢多元文化主义，汤姆。不，多米尼克。试图写一部关于世界上某个角落的史诗，而那个角落
everyone knows is there and saying that it's full of monsters. But to stick up for Apollonius, Apollonius obviously thinks that it's an entirely legitimate what he's doing because otherwise he wouldn't write his epic. Of course. And he thinks that Calimachus is the idiot. So like you. And he wrote this one,
每个人都知道它就在那里，却说它充满了怪物，这本身就有一种山寨的特质。但为了支持阿波罗尼斯，阿波罗尼斯显然认为他做的事情完全合情合理，否则他也不会写他的史诗了。当然。而且他认为卡利马库斯是个白痴。所以就像你一样。他写了这样一首
line poem, which is kind of structured like an entry in an encyclopedia. And he sums up Klimachus as trash, a cheap joke, a blockhead. I love Apollonius. I think it sounds brilliant. That's exactly what I would do. And I think that his defense of the Argonautica wouldn't just have been that it's, you know, a thrilling page turner. What's wrong with a thrilling page turner? You know, they're great. But also he would say he's doing something much more with it. And specifically, what he is doing, he would say, I think, is that he is adapting myth. You know, this great inheritance of the stories of the gods and the heroes to the age of Alexander's successors, which is an age of global horizons, of kings who claim to be gods, and of teeming
单行诗，它的结构有点像百科全书里的词条。他把卡利马库斯概括为垃圾、低级笑话、笨蛋。我太喜欢阿波罗尼斯了。我觉得这听起来太棒了。这正是我会做的事。我认为他对《阿尔戈英雄纪》的辩护不仅会是它是一部（你知道的）惊心动魄、让人爱不释卷的书——一本惊心动魄的翻页书有什么不好？（你知道的，它们很棒。）而且他还会说，他在其中融入了更多、更深远的东西。具体来说，他会说，他所做的是在改编神话——
megacities that had not existed when, you know, Sophocles, let alone Homer was writing their masterpieces. All right. Well, let's take a break, Tom. And then when we come back after the break, let's look or talk about Alexander and his influence on what we've come to call Greek mythology. And let's look at what happens to this corpus of Greek stories and the way the Greeks understand the supernatural in the wake of Alexander's conquests.
（你知道的，将神祇和英雄故事的这份伟大遗产）适应当下亚历山大继业者的时代。这是一个拥有全球化视野的时代，国王们自称为神，并且这里涌现出繁星般的特大城市，而在（你知道的）索福克勒斯甚至荷马创作杰作的年代，这些城市根本不存在。好了，好吧，我们休息一下，汤姆。然后等我们休息回来后，让我们来看看或谈谈亚历山大及其对我们现在所谓希腊神话的影响。让我们看看在亚历山大征服的浪潮之后，这批希腊故事库以及希腊人理解超自然的方式发生了什么变化。
This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered, it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today.
本期节目由 Uber 赞助播出。嘿，你有没有那种感觉：当你最需要的时候，总有人为你挺身而出？我们有时都需要这种支持，Uber 深知这一点。Uber 不仅仅是一次行程或一顿外卖，它代表着无论如何都会为你出现。就像为你远方的朋友在他们生病时送去热汤，在他们情绪低落时送上鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论发生什么，你都会挺身而出。只要有心，我们就在路上。Uber，在路上。今天就下载应用程序吧。
Welcome back to. the rest is history. Now, we promised you Alexander the Great. Alexander the Great, of course, was famously devoted to the stories of Greek myth and legend. So there's a story, isn't there, that he travels with a copy of the Iliad, a sort of very fancy folio society edition of the Iliad that he puts under his pillow. And he clearly is a very God-fearing or God's-fearing man, because when he crosses the Hellers-Pond, for example, he builds an altar to the the 12 Olympians. And he was obsessed particularly with Achilles. I mean, he thinks of himself and his friend Hefeistian as the modern day Achilles and Patroclus. And he takes all this
欢迎回到《余下历史》。现在，我们向您承诺过亚历山大大帝。亚历山大大帝，当然，以痴迷于希腊神话和传奇故事而闻名。所以有一个故事，不是吗？他随身带着一本《伊利亚特》的副本，那是傅尔社（Folio Society）出版的一种非常精美的对开本《伊利亚特》，他把它放在枕头底下。他显然是一个非常敬畏神明的人，因为比如当他穿过赫勒斯滂海峡时，他为奥林匹斯十二主神建立了一座祭坛。他特别着迷于阿喀琉斯。我的意思是，他把自已和他的朋友赫费斯提翁视为现代的阿喀琉斯和帕特洛克罗斯。他把这一切都
incredibly seriously, doesn't he, Tom? He does. He comes to think that he's literally the son of Zeus. Yeah. He goes to the Oracle of Siwa. Yeah. When he reaches what's now Afghanistan, he sees traces all around him of Dionysus, who was supposed to have traveled there many, many centuries before. So he sees kind of stone burial heaps that are covered with ivy and Ivy was sacred to Dionysus and so Alexander assumes that these were boundary stones that have been set up by the god. Alexander's ambition is to go even further than Dionysus. So to quote Arrian, the Roman historian writing in the second century AD, he confidently expected his troops would join him in this done as it would be in imitation of Dionysus's achievements. But Dominic, that doesn't happen,
看得无比认真，不是吗，汤姆？他是的。他甚至认为自己 literalmente（字面上）就是宙斯的儿子。是的。他去了锡瓦绿洲的神谕所。是的。当他到达现在的阿富汗时，他在周围到处看到了狄奥尼索斯的痕迹，据说狄奥尼索斯在许多许多世纪前曾到过那里。所以他看到了一些被常春藤覆盖的石质墓葬堆，而常春藤对狄奥尼索斯来说是神圣的，因此亚历山大认为这些是神明设立的界碑。亚历山大的野心是走得比狄奥尼索斯更远。因此，引用公元2世纪罗马历史学家阿里安的话，他满怀信心地期望他的军队会加入他的这项壮举，正如这将是对狄奥尼索斯成就的模仿。但是多米尼克，事实并非如此，
does it? No, so he's never defeated, but he's defeated by his own men in India on the river Hyphasis. They force him to turn back in three, two, six. Yet again, he built an altar to the gods. I mean, Alexander, he just, he loves doing two things, basically founding cities called Alexandria, building altars. And then he goes back to Babylon. And three years later, he's dead in Babylon, probably in malaria, possibly a poison. We can't be sure. Or is he, Tom? Is he dead? So Alexander is obviously angling to be worshipped as a god, and this is a conceit that is treated with absolute contempt by, say, the Athenians. I mean, they see this as an example of the insane megalomania. But the thing is, it doesn't actually take long for the Athenians to hail one of Alexander's successors in person as a god. So not long after Alexander's death, only a few decades in 2.95, you have this Macedonian strong man called Demetrius the Bess. Sieger, which I always thought it's a brilliant subricate, yeah. Polyoketes, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. And he comes to Athens and occupies it, and he addresses the Athenians in the theatre of Dionysus, where the tragedies have been staged. And he appears there as though he is, you know, a hero or maybe even a god, kind of deus ex machina appearing there. And four years later, he comes back to Athens and he's overtly greeted as though he were Dionysus, as though, you know, he has appeared, as though it's the amphisteria. And he's accompanied. And he's a need into Athens by dancers carrying giant fallacies. And the Athenians hail him with this kind of
对吧？没错，所以他从未被击败，但在印度的希法西斯河畔，他被自己的人民击败了。他们在公元前326年迫使他折返。他再次为神明建造了一座祭坛。我的意思是，亚历山大，他只是——他最喜欢做两件事：基本上是建立名叫亚历山大里亚的城市，以及建造祭坛。然后他回到了巴比伦。三年后，他在巴比伦去世，死因可能是疟疾，也可能是中毒。我们无法确定。或者他真的死了吗，汤姆？他死了吗？所以亚历山大显然在极力争取被当作神来崇拜，这种自负遭到了雅典人等绝对的鄙视。我的意思是，他们认为这是疯狂的巨额狂妄（megalomania）的一个例子。但问题是，雅典人并没有花很长时间去亲自欢呼亚历山大的一位继业者为神。因此，在亚历山大死后不久，仅仅几十年后的公元前295年，出现了一位名叫德米特里乌斯的马其顿强人，被称为“攻城者”（Besse)——
poem. The other gods are far distant or have no ears or do not exist or ignore us. But we can see before us, you are not made of stone or wood. No, you are real. And they hail Demetrius as Sota, as saviour, and they allow him to live with his mistress in a back room of the Parthenon up on the Acropolis, the great temple to Athena on the Acropolis, and Demetrius very modestly begins to refer to Athena as his sister. And that's just not his own ego, right? Because this is becoming a trend across the Hellenistic world. And I'm wondering, a lot of this must come from Egypt, from the Ptolemies, who are being worshipped as gods. And actually, Ptolemy the first, calls himself Sota, doesn't he, the Savior? So this is becoming a trend for kings,
“围攻者”，我一直觉得这是一个绝妙的绰号，对吧？波奥尔基泰斯（Polyorketes），不是吗？对。对。他来到雅典并占领了它，他在狄奥尼索斯剧院向雅典人发表讲话，悲剧曾在这里上演。他出现在那里，仿佛他是一个英雄，甚至可能是一个神，有点像 deus ex machina（机械降神）出现在那里。四年后，他回到雅典，被公开当作狄奥尼索斯来迎接，仿佛他——你知道的，他已经出现，就像安特斯特里亚节（Anthesteria）一样。他随行。他被带着巨型阴茎模型的舞者簇拥着进入雅典。雅典人以这样一首
would you say, across the Hellenistic era, to identify themselves of the gods? And I think you're right that it's part of a kind of cultural soup, but I think it's also reflecting a sense that the Olympians are not there for people in their kind of hour of need, that the old rituals and cults that had seemed to keep Athens in the favor of the gods are no longer functioning. The corollary of this in turn is a kind of growing public skepticism among intellectuals about the Olympians full stop. So there is one book in particular that becomes an absolute bestseller in exactly this period. And you can see why, when I tell you what it's seem is, it's written by a philosopher called Euhmerus. And he comes up with a kind of very novel explanation for the ancient myths. He's kind of Graham Hancock of the ancient world. And he wrote that this book is called the Sacred Register.
诗来欢呼他：“其他神明都远在天边，或者没有耳朵，或者根本不存在，或者对我们视而不见。但我们可以亲眼看到你，你不是由石头或木头制成的。不，你是真实的。”他们欢呼德米特里乌斯为索托斯（Soter），即拯救者，并允许他和他的情妇住在雅典卫城帕特农神庙（雅典卫城献给雅典娜的宏伟大神庙）后方的一个房间里，而德米特里乌斯非常谦虚地开始称雅典娜为他的妹妹。这不仅仅是他个人的虚荣心，对吧？因为这正在成为整个希腊化世界的一种潮流。我在想，这很大一部分一定来自埃及，来自那些被当作神来崇拜的托勒密家族。实际上，托勒密一世就自称为索托斯，不是吗，即拯救者？所以这正在成为国王们的一种潮流，
And in it, Eucharist claims that he'd been sent on a diplomatic mission by one of the Macedonians to an island in the Indian Ocean. And there he had found an inscription written in hieroglyphics. And this is the Sacred Register. So it's very Graham Hancock. And the Sacred Register reveals a bombshell truth, which is that Zeus hadn't been a god at all. He'd been a mortal king of Crete, who after his death had come to be worshipped as a god,
你会这么说吗，在整个希腊化时代，国王们将自己等同于神明？我认为你是对的，这是某种文化大熔炉的一部分，但我也认为这反映了一种感觉，即奥林匹斯神明在人们需要的时候并不会出现，那些曾经让雅典保持在神明恩宠中的古老仪式和崇拜已经不再发挥作用了。这随之而来的必然结果是，知识分子对奥林匹斯神明的全面公开怀疑日益增长。因此，有一本书在这一时期绝对成为了畅销书。当你听到它的主题时，你就会明白为什么了：它是由一位名叫欧赫迈罗斯（Euhemerus）的哲学家写的。他为古代神话提出了一种非常新颖的解释。他有点像是古代世界的格雷厄姆·汉考克（Graham Hancock）。他写了这本书，书名叫《圣册》（The Sacred Register）。
and that this was true of all the other Olympians as well. They were all been mortals, and they'd been raised up to the heavens. And the popularity of this thesis suggests just how large a market it there has come to be by the third century BC for works of philosophy, that it's no longer the kind of researche habit that has been under Plato, it's becoming kind of becoming part of the mainstream. So actually to go back to the last episode where we were talking about philosophers establishing themselves in opposition to poets and storytellers, initially they were out there
在书中，欧赫迈罗斯声称他被其中一位马其顿统治者派往印度洋的一个岛屿执行外交任务。在那里，他发现了一块用象形文字写成的铭文。这就是《圣册》。所以这非常具有格雷厄姆·汉考克的风格。而《圣册》揭示了一个重磅真相：宙斯根本不是神。他曾是克里特岛的一个凡人国王，在他死后才被当作神来崇拜，
in their little, you know, their academy outside the city, but their ideas have clearly percolated more deeply over the centuries, and now would it be an exaggeration to say that by and large now in the Hellenistic era, if you are a self-respecting intellectual, in other words, in other words, if you're the kind of person who's hanging around to the museum in Alexandria, you are skeptical about the stories of the Olympians and you say, come on, this stuff is obviously rubbish. Yeah. There aren't people with the heads of this and turning themselves into eagles and sleeping
所有其他的奥林匹斯神明也都是如此。他们全都是凡人，死后被提升到了天堂。这一论点的受欢迎程度表明，到公元前3世纪，哲学作品的市场已经变得多么庞大，它不再是柏拉图统治下那种曲高和寡的习俗，而是正在成为主流的一部分。所以，实际上回到上一期节目，我们谈到哲学家们将自己确立为与诗人和讲故事的人对立的立场时，最初他们在城市外面他们的小小（你知道的）学院里，但几个世纪以来，他们的思想显然已经更加深入地渗透了进来，现在如果说在希腊化时代，如果你是一个有自我尊严的知识分子——换句话说，换句话说，如果你是那种在亚历山大里亚的缪斯宫（Museum）闲逛的人——你对奥林匹斯神话持怀疑态度，并且会说：“得了吧，这东西显然是胡扯。”这会是夸大其词吗？是的。
with women. That's obviously rubbish. Yes, I think it is. And again, I mean, it's like, you know, all comparisons. have their problems. But perhaps there's a slight element of the way in which most intellectuals would be embarrassed to say that they believe that God became a baby and was born from a virgin, that kind of thing. Yeah. Yep. Yep. Yeah. And a bit like with the rejection of institutional Christianity today by intellectuals, the rejection of the stories told of the Olympian gods
没有什么长着这种脑袋的人，也没有把自己变成老鹰并与女性同床共枕的事。那显然是胡扯。是的，我想确实如此。再说一次，我的意思是，这就像——你知道的，所有的比较都有其问题。但也许其中存在着这样一种微小的相似之处：大多数知识分子会为自己说出“相信上帝变成了一个婴儿并由处女所生”之类的话感到尴尬，诸如此类。是的。没错。没错。是的。而且，正如今天知识分子对体制化基督教的拒绝一样，
by intellectuals in the Hellenistic world is often cast as a kind of triumph of reason over superstition and of self-examination over blind faith. But this itself is a myth because just as intellectuals today who think that they have rejected, you know, the superstitions of the past actually are merely propagating new forms of that superstition. So you can see in the Hellenistic world, the rejection of what philosophers come to cast as superstition breeds its own superstitions. Okay. Interesting.
希腊化时代的知识分子对奥林匹斯诸神传说的拒绝，通常被描绘成一种理性对迷信的胜利，以及自我审视对盲目信仰的胜利。但这本身就是一个神话，因为正如今天那些认为自己已经抛弃了（你知道的）过去迷信的知识分子实际上只是在传播这种迷信的新形式一样，你也可以在希腊化时代看到，哲学家们贬斥为迷信的东西，其被拒绝的过程本身也孕育出了它自己的迷信。好吧，有趣。
So I, and I would say that what is happening in the Hellenistic world is that kind of notions of the supernatural that have been appropriate to a world of small city states is now being adapted to a kind of vast, globalized one with megacities. Right. The classic example of what this meant in practice, a guy called Epicurus, who is the son of Athenian settlers on Samos. He'd been a boy back when. Alexander had crossed the Hellespont, and he ends up in Athens, where he teaches a vision of
所以，我要说的是，希腊化时代正在发生的事情是，原本适应于小城邦世界的超自然概念，现在正在被改编以适应一个庞大的、全球化的、拥有特大城市的庞然大物。对吧。这种实践中含义的经典例子，是一个名叫伊壁鸠鲁（Epicurus）的人，他是萨摩斯岛上雅典定居者的儿子。当亚历山大穿过赫勒斯滂海峡时，他还是个男孩，他最终来到了雅典，在那里他传授了一种关于宇宙的愿景，
the universe that is very atomistic. He teaches that everything is made up of atoms. And in due course, this will make him a great hero of re thinkers and skeptics in the Enlightenment. But Epicurus is absolutely not an atheist, and he is still less a kind of rationalist. He did believe in gods. it's just that the gods he believed in were gods who didn't intervene in human affairs and did not control the destiny of the world and his interest in the natural world so all this kind of stuff about atoms and things
这种愿景是非常原子论的。他教导说，一切事物都是由原子组成的。假以时日，这将使他成为启蒙运动中自由思想家和怀疑论者的伟大英雄。但伊壁鸠鲁绝对不是无神论者，他更谈不上是什么理性主义者。他确实相信神的存在；只是他所相信的神是不干预人类事务、不控制世界命运的神。他对自然世界的兴趣——所有关于原子之类的事物——
it's not because he's some kind of proto-scientist that is absolutely not what Epicurus is about to this day there are rationalists who say oh Epicurus he's brilliant you know he's a kind of proto-scient he's the opposite the only reason Epicurus has for researching the nature of things is to appreciate the pointlessness of believing in myths. And this is because in turn, it will lead to the state of tranquility atyxia in Greek
并不是因为他是什么早期科学家的原型，这绝对不是伊壁鸠鲁的本质。直到今天，还有一些理性主义者说：“哦，伊壁鸠鲁，他太棒了（你知道的），他某种程度上是早期科学的先驱。”恰恰相反。伊壁鸠鲁研究事物本质的唯一原因，是为了体会相信神话是毫无意义的。而这反过来又将导致一种平静的状态，即希腊语中的 ataraxia（宁静），
that Epicurus sees as being the ultimate goal of existence. So effectively what he's doing is saying turn on, tune in, drop out. It's a completely radical rejection of the assumptions of classical Athens. And that's why there's a lot of hostility towards Epicurus. but it's not like he's saying go out and become a, you know, invent nuclear physics or something like that. He's basically, I mean, basically, he's less Richard Dawkins. He's much more than Maharishi. Right.
伊壁鸠鲁将其视为生存的终极目标。所以实际上他在做的事情是：不要理会世俗，保持同频，选择退隐。这是对古典雅典假设的彻底激进的拒绝。这就是为什么人们对伊壁鸠鲁有很多敌意。但这并不是说他在呼吁大家去成为一个（你知道的）发明核物理学之类的人。他基本上——我的意思是，基本上，他不太像理查德·道金斯（Richard Dawkins）。他更像是玛哈利许（Maharishi，超觉静坐创始人）。对。
He's somebody who says sort of ignore all the silly rituals and stuff of the stuffy squares. What we need to, he's like the kind of person who drops out to become a Buddhist in the 1960s. Is that basically what it is? Yeah. Well, you know, Buddhism is a kind of noble ancient tradition. There's a strong element of the charlatan about. Epicurus. So he's like somebody talking about New Age crystals,
他就像那种在20世纪60年代退隐去当佛教徒的人。基本上是这样吗？嗯，你知道的，佛教是一种崇高的古代传统。而伊壁鸠鲁身上带有很强的江湖骗子色彩。所以他就像那种谈论新时代水晶的人，
that kind of thing. He's a profound a philosopher than that. I mean, there are Epicureans to this day who will not like that categorization. You know, so all the papy scrolls in Herculaneum that are starting to be deciphered now are by Epicureans, which is slightly frustrating.
诸如此类。他是一个比这深刻得多的哲学家。我的意思是，直到今天还有一些伊壁鸠鲁学派的人不会喜欢这种分类。（你知道的，赫库兰尼姆现在开始被解读的所有纸莎草纸卷都是伊壁鸠鲁学派的，这有点令人沮丧。）
But Epicureus himself, I mean, there are definite qualities of, you know, the guru. So he sets up effectively a commune in Athens, which is funded by his wealthy admirers. Epicurus is not remotely in favour of allowing his followers to think for themselves. So his dictum is always act always as though Epicurus is watching. So he's a kind of big brother. Right. And his admirers, while he's alive, call him the leader. And then when he
但伊壁鸠鲁本人——我的意思是，确实有古鲁（导师）的特质。所以他实际上在雅典建立了一个公社，由他富有的崇拜者资助。伊壁鸠鲁一点也不赞成让他的追随者独立思考。所以他的名言一直是：行事永远要表现得好像伊壁鸠鲁在看着你一样。所以他有点像老大哥。对。当他还活着时，他的崇拜者称他为领袖。然后当他
dies, they call him Sota, saviour. God. So he really is like a cult leader. You know, this is an age where people are looking for a savior. And when he dies, I mean, considering that Epicurus had absolutely rejected the notion of interventionist gods, I mean, Epicurus is, you know, he's he's remembered very much like an interventionist god so he while he was alive he'd referred to his body as being something holy um he demanded the first fruits from his followers so that's you know the first the first fruits for the harvest which is conventionally what you pay to the Olympian gods and then after his death they hold commemorative feasts so he's kind of you know it's looking back to the Olympian gods it's looking forward to the kind of the way that
去世后，他们称他为索托斯（拯救者）、神。所以他真的很像一个邪教领袖。（你知道的，这是一个人们在寻找拯救者的时代。）当他去世时——考虑到伊壁鸠鲁完全拒绝了干预主义神的观念——我的意思是，伊壁鸠鲁（你知道的）被铭记的方式非常像一个干预主义的神：他在世时曾将自己的身体称为某种神圣的东西，嗯，他要求追随者献上初熟的果实——也就是（你知道的）收获季的初熟果实，这通常是你向奥林匹斯诸神支付的东西——然后在死后，他们举行纪念宴会。所以这某种程度上（你知道的）是在回溯奥林匹斯诸神，也是在展望基督徒纪念基督的方式。
Christians will commemorate Christ epicurus is not an embodiment of enlightened rationalism, I think it's fair to say. And, you know, there's that famous comment Chesterton makes that, and you can adapt it, that when the Greeks choose not to believe in the Olympians, it's not that they don't believe in, you know, they don't believe in nothing. They become capable of believing in anything, basically. So to go back to Jason the Argonaut, so what that's reflecting, therefore, is an age where there's a genuine kind of a massive flux of ideas, where the old institutions,
伊壁鸠鲁并不是开明理性主义的化身，我认为这样说挺公允的。而且，（你知道的）切斯特顿（Chesterton）有一句著名的评论，你可以对其进行调整：当雅典人选择不相信奥林匹斯诸神时，并不是说他们不相信——你知道的，他们什么都不信。他们变得基本上能够相信任何事情。所以回到阿尔戈英雄伊阿宋，这所反映的因此是一个思想经历巨大剧烈变动的时代，在这个时代里，旧机构、
the old sort of rituals and assumptions have lost some of their power over people and people are picking and choosing much more as they will do in like 1970s America or something. They're questing. Yes, exactly. They're searching for meaning. Yes, exactly.
旧的仪式和假设对人们失去了一些权力，人们更加随心所欲地挑选，就像他们在20世纪70年代的美国或类似地方所做的那样。他们在探索。是的，完全正确。他们在寻找意义。是的，完全正确。
So kind of hanging out in the garden and dropping out is one option. There's another option which is hinted at quite strongly in Eucharist's book because Eucharist, I mean, he's not an atheist either. He thinks that the Olympians were originally more but he does think that there are gods, but he thinks that the gods are planets. And this is another thing that is obviously influenced by Egyptian, Babylonian traditions,
所以，在花园里闲逛并退隐是一种选择。还有另一种选择，在欧赫迈罗斯的书中有相当强烈的暗示，因为欧赫迈罗斯——我的意思是，他也不是无神论者。他认为奥林匹斯诸神最初是凡人，但他确实认为有神明存在，不过他认为这些神明是行星。这是另一种明显受到埃及、巴比伦传统影响的事物，
you know, the Greek kings of Egypt and of, you know, the Seleukids, they have access to this kind of very, very ancient astronomical, astrological inheritance. And so this is a way in which the Olympians actually kind of make a return for Greek intellectuals, is that the planets come to be identified with the Greek gods. So the swiftest planet is the planet that comes to be called Hermes, the messenger of the gods, and the Romans call Mercury. And we still call it Mercury to this day. The brightest, most beautiful planet, Aphrodite, aka Venus.
（你知道的，埃及的希腊国王和塞琉古国王可以接触到这种非常非常古老的占星术、天文遗产。）因此，这是奥林匹斯诸神实际上对希腊知识分子卷土重来的一种方式，即行星开始与希腊神明划上等号。最快的行星后来被称为赫尔墨斯，即诸神的信使，罗马人称之为水星。我们直到今天仍然称它为水星。最亮、最美丽的行星是阿弗洛狄忒，也就是维纳斯。
The bloodiest planet, the planet that's the color of blood, is Ares, the god of war, or Mars. And of course, the largest planet, that's the king of the gods, Zeus, or as we call it Jupiter. But the thing is that the rule of these planetary Olympians is much, much more tyrannical than the rule of the traditional Olympian gods had been because the planets can't be swayed by festivals or by, you know, sacrifices or anything like that. They're completely indifferent.
最血腥的行星，也就是带有血色颜色的行星，是阿瑞斯，战神，或者叫火星。当然，最大的行星，那是诸神之王，宙斯，或者正如我们所称的木星。但问题是，这些行星奥林匹斯神的统治，比传统奥林匹斯诸神的统治要专制得多，因为行星无法被节日、祭祀或任何类似的东西所左右。它们完全是冷漠的。
They're chill. The doom that's written in the stars if you believe in astrology is something that you can't escape. And there's always been an element of fatalism. There's always been an element of fatalism in the Greek understanding of the divine and whatnot, hasn't there? But it's become more pronounced now, would you say? I think if you believe that your fate is locked into the stars, all you can do, the best you can do is to try and learn what it is
它们冷酷无情。如果你相信占星术，那写在星星里的厄运是你无法逃脱的。希腊人对神圣事物及其他事物的理解中，一直存在着一种宿命论的成分，不是吗？但现在这种成分变得更加明显了，你会这么说吗？我认为，如果你相信自己的命运与星辰紧紧锁在一起，你所能做的、你能做的最好事情，就是试图去了解它是什么，
by becoming a massive kind of astrology fan. But there is an even bleaker possibility, which also becomes very widespread in this period, that there is no order at all, and that the greatest of all gods is Taiki, so Greek for fate for fortune and that there is therefore you know there's no pattern there there's no logos there's no possibility of fathoming an order in the universe because there isn't one so an Athenian poet put it in kind of very devastating terms it's not Logos which guides
方法就是成为一个狂热的占星术粉丝。但还有一种更加暗淡的可能性，在这一时期也变得非常普遍，那就是根本没有任何秩序，所有神明中最伟大的是堤喀（Tyche），即希腊语中的命运、运气，因此（你知道的）那里没有模式，没有逻各斯（logos），不可能参透宇宙中的秩序，因为根本没有秩序。正如一位雅典诗人以一种极具毁灭性的方式所表达的：引导凡人事务的不是逻各斯，
the affairs of mortals but Taiki so you were saying this is an age where people are looking around for answers and solutions and some of these answers and solutions are very bleak so Now, I think astrology is very bleak. It tells you what's going to happen. There's nothing you can do to affect it. And if you think that that Taiki is the goddess that controls everything, then a philosopher sums it up well. Her influence on our lives is as beyond computation
而是堤喀。所以你刚才说这是一个人们四处寻找答案和解决方案的时代，其中一些答案和解决方案非常黯淡。现在，我认为占星术非常黯淡。它告诉你将要发生什么。你无能为力去改变它。如果你认为堤喀是控制一切的女神，那么一位哲学家很好地总结了这一点：“她对我们生活的影响，正如她力量的表现一样，超越了计算，且完全不可预测。”
as the manifestations of her power are unpredictable. And yet, so we've been talking about philosophers, but what do the people in the streets of Athens or Alexandria, the taverns in the marketplaces, is what do they think? Because there's always a danger when we're talking about belief that we over-emphasise the importance of that minority of people who really, really care about these things and talk about them a lot.
然而，尽管我们一直在谈论哲学家，但雅典或亚历山大,里亚街头的普通人、集市上的酒馆里的人，他们在想什么呢？因为当我们谈论信仰时，总存在着这样一种危险：我们过分强调了那一小部分真正、真正关心这些事情并经常谈论它们的人的重要性。
But most people, of course, don't. They're interested in the price of bread or whatever. So Jason and the Argonauts would not have been so successful, presumably, unless there were loads of punters who loved this kind of thing and who genuinely thought that it had meaning, presumably. The old rituals that had sustained the independent Greek city states carry on even though they're no longer independent. And for some, you know, it becomes like the equivalent of the trooping of the color
但大多数人，当然，并不这样。他们关心的是面包的价格之类的东西。所以，伊阿宋和阿尔戈英雄如果没有一大群热爱这种东西并真心认为它有意义的拥趸，大概就不会那么成功了，对吧？那些维持独立希腊城邦的古老仪式依然在继续，尽管它们已经不再独立了。对某些人来说，（你知道的）这变得就像是军旗敬礼分列式（trooping of the colour）或巴士底日一样。我的意思是，这差不多就是它的极限了。但我认为对许多人来说，他们确实继续感到神明是无处不在的（immanent），通过践行这些仪式和节日，他们正在与神明进行交流。但我认为，也有些知识分子显然怀念那些爱他们的神明。阿波罗尼斯就是其中的代表。阿波罗尼斯在写《阿尔戈英雄纪》时，并不是作为一个乡巴佬。他不是以一个不完全理解自己在做什么的人的身份去写的，
or Bastille Day. I mean, that's kind of the limit of it. But I think for lots of people, they do continue to feel that the gods are imminent and that by practicing these rituals and these festivals, they are in communion with the gods. But I think also there are intellectuals who clearly miss the gods who love them. And Apollonius would be representative of that. Apollonius, when he writes the Argonautica, is not doing it as a hick. He's not doing it as someone who doesn't understand exactly what he's doing,
因为他和卡利马库斯一样，是一位非常、非常伟大的学者。他们都在希腊化时代产生的所有研究机构中最伟大的机构里工作——我们做过一期关于它的节目——也就是亚历山大里亚图书馆。所以卡利马库斯这个人，除了写晦涩难懂的诗歌之外，还起草了图书馆的目录（你知道的，绝对是宏大的成果）。而阿波罗尼斯是一位研究荷马的学术专家。所以当他以荷马为原型创作史诗时，他知道自己在谈论什么。
because he, like Callimachus, is a very, very great scholar. And they are both employed in the greatest of all the kind of research institutes that the Hellenistic period throws up, and we've done an episode on it, namely the Library of Alexandria. So Calimachus is the guy, as well as writing Recondite poetry. He's drawn up the catalogue of the library, you know, absolutely massive product. And Apollonius is an academic specialist on Homer. So when he's writing an epic on the Homeric model, he knows what he's talking about.
他一直参与起草荷马的正统文本，这是亚历山大里亚的学者们非常热衷做的事情。他做得如此出色，以至于最终成为了亚历山大里亚的首席图书馆员，并且把卡利马库斯给挤掉了。这就是为什么尽管有些学者对这两人之间存在文学竞争的想法持怀疑态度，但我认为确实存在。因为我认为这正是那种可能会让（你知道的）他们恨透对方的事情。所以你可以看到，《阿尔戈英雄纪》尽管是一部充满欢趣、引人入胜且极具娱乐性的好书，但它也是别的东西。它是一项研究，是对神话的逻各斯（logos）。所以它是一部神话学（mythologia）。对。那么在亚历山大里亚，像阿波罗尼斯这样的人正在发生的事情是，神话正在变成神话学。那么请为我们区分一下你所指的
He's been involved drawing up the kind of the canonical text of Homer, which is something that scholars in Alexandria are really keen on doing it. He does it so well that he ends up becoming the chief librarian of Alexandria and he pips, Kalimachus to the job. And so that's why although there is skepticism among some scholars about the idea of this literary rivalry between the two men, I think there was. because I think that's exactly the kind of thing that would have probably, you know, they would have absolutely hated each other. And so you can see that the Argonautica, even though it's a rollic and good read and tremendous entertainment, it is also something else. It is a study, a logos of myths. So it is a mythologia. Right. And so what is happening in Alexandria with people like Apollonius is that myth is becoming mythology. So just distinguish for us what you mean by the
神话与神话学之间的区别。所以区别也许在于神话学更加具有自我意识、更加怀旧和向后看，你觉得呢？它是对神话的研究。对。它是带着对其背景的意识来讲述神话，并且你以一种文学或学术的方式来进行。所以，（你知道的）一本儿童读物是一个合集，（你知道的）是一部神话学作品或讲述神话学的作品。作家并不相信其中的任何内容，而是将各种元素组合在一起，讲述一个好故事。但在它的最高层面上，它产出了非凡的文学作品。神话就是通过这种方式进入欧洲文化的血液中的。所以罗马人在写神话学。因此，当维吉尔改编荷马
difference in myth and mythology. So is the difference maybe that mythology is more self-conscious and nostalgic and backward-looking, do you think? It's the study of myths. Right. It's the telling of myths with an awareness of their backstory and that you were doing it in a kind of a literary or scholarly manner. So, you know, a children's book is a collection, you know, is a work of mythology or telling mythology. The writer doesn't believe any of it is drawing kind of various elements and putting them together to tell a good story. But at its highest level, it results in extraordinary works of literature. And this is how the myths pass into the bloodstream of European culture. So the Romans are writing mythology. So Virgil, when he adapts Homer
来讲述这部宏大的史诗时，他汲取了特洛伊战争和《奥德赛》的故事，解释了罗马的开端与起源，《埃涅阿斯纪》就是一部神话学作品。对。维吉尔并不认为它是真实的。维吉尔身上——几乎带有一点点微不足道的古物研究色彩。确实带有古物研究的色彩。我的意思是，他是否认为它是真实的，这是一个复杂的问题。但它并不是以荷马为希腊人定义神话的那种方式来为罗马人总结神话。还有奥维德，他写了这部关于变形故事的宏大合集《变形记》，或者中世纪、文艺复兴直到现代时期的作家和艺术家们，（希腊神话）是希腊神话的宏大宝库。它是莎士比亚、提香、伊阿宋与阿尔戈英雄、儿童（你知道的）《波西·杰克逊》等所有作品汲取灵感的宝库。神话就是这样得以延续的。因为如果你有了神话学，你就有了神话。
to tell this great epic drawing on stories of the Trojan War and the Odyssey that explains the beginning, the origins of Rome, the aneerneed is a work of mythology. Right. Virgil doesn't think it's real. Virgil is, there's a slight maybe a tiny bit of an antiquarian element to it almost. There is an antiquarian element. I mean, whether he thinks it's real or not as complicated question. But it's not summing up myth for the Romans in the way that Homer defines myth for the Greeks. And you have Ovid as well, who writes this great collection of stories of transformations, metamorphoses,
神话被嵌入在神话学之中。但是，难道它们之所以能够延续，不也是因为——你知道的，虽然我知道你讨厌用“宗教”这个词，但我只是非常宽泛地使用它。有那么多的古代宗教是通过仪式、通过实践来定义的。但使希腊神话——换个更好的词——变得与众不同的是它们的故事。它们最初是诗歌。正因为如此，它们得以延续，而巴比伦人甚至埃及人的故事（你知道的）在我们看来并不令人满意，而希腊神话则不然，因为他们更多的是仪式化的，而不是文学化的。希腊神话
or writers and artists through the Middle Ages, the Renaissance into the modern period, is the great storehouse of Greek myth. It's the storehouse that Shakespeare draws on, Titian, Jason the Ogonauts, children's, you know, Percy Jackson, all of that. That's how the myths endure. Because if you have mythology, you have myth.
一直都是文学化的。是的，我认为这绝对是对的。我认为这就是为什么它们吸引儿童，吸引（你知道的）像尼采和弗洛伊德这样著名的知识分子。它们以其他任何神话都无法比拟的方式，成为了伟大作家和艺术家灵感的源泉。是的。而且它们延续至今。这就是为什么我们可以做一个关于希腊神话的系列节目。也许还有北欧神话，因为它们也是纯粹作为故事而不是作为表演或仪式传给我们的。但我认为那略有不同，因为希腊神话来自于信仰的炽热核心。北欧史诗是在对神明的信仰消逝很久之后才被写下来的。因此它们带有各种各样的杂质。
The myth is embedded within the mythology. But also, don't they endure because, you know, so many, I know you hate using the word, religion, but I'm just going to use it very loosely. So many ancient religions were defined through ritual, through ritual, through practice. But what makes the Greek myths form of a better word distinctive is their stories. They began as poems. And that that's why they endure in a way that the stories of the Babylonians or even the Egyptians, you know, they seem unsatisfying to us in a way that the Greek myths aren't because they were ritualistic rather than literary. The Greek myths were
这就解释了它们的效力。不过，这里有一个缺点：因为它是通过神话学为我们中介的，由那些以略微绝对的方式研究它的人中介的。而且因为经过几代人和几个世纪的发展，它一直被那些根本不相信其中任何内容的人世代延续着。这就是我们得到的遗产。这对我们来说很困难，因为我们的假设往往是唯物主义和基督教的。（你知道的）我们有一种文化覆盖层。我们很难重新进入希腊人自己的心态，很难回到索福克勒斯、欧里庇得斯的时代，甚至更难回到荷马的时代。但我认为，如果不去尝试想象自己身处这样一个世界：在这个世界里，神明是各个希腊城邦生活中以及更广泛宇宙中的主要行动者，你就无法真正理解希腊人，因为只有在那时，我们才能正确地看到希腊人是如何看待他们自己的。是的。而且，我越来越觉得关于希腊古典时期及之前的几个世纪，最大的挑战
always literary. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. And I think that's why they appeal to children and they appeal to, you know, famous intellectuals like Nietzsche and Freud. And they've served as an inspiration to great writers and artists in a way that no other mythology has done. Yeah. And they continue to this day. And that's why we can do a series on Greek myths. Possibly the Norse myths, because they also have come down to us purely as stories rather than as performance or ritual. But I think that's slightly different because the Greek myths are coming from the molten heart of belief. The Norse epics are written long after the belief in the gods. And so they have all kinds of contaminations.
就在于试着想象自己回到这样一个世界：在这个世界里，你可以逃离神话学，重新进入一个神话的世界，可以这么说。非常美妙。总结得非常精妙，汤姆。
That explains their potency. There is a drawback, though, which is that because it's mediated for us by mythology, by people who are studying it in a kind of slightly absolute. way. And because over the course of the generations and the centuries, it's been perpetuated by people who do not believe any of it at all. And that's the inheritance that we get. It is difficult for us because our assumptions tend to be materialist and Christian. You know, we have kind of a cultural overlay. It is difficult for us to get back into the mindset of the Greeks themselves, to get back into the age of Sophocles and Euripides and still more of Homer. But I think, you cannot properly understand the Greeks without trying to imagine yourself in a world
这就解释了它们的威力。不过，这里有一个缺点，那就是因为它是通过神话媒介传达给我们的，是通过那些以某种略显绝对的方式研究它的人传达给我们的。而且由于在世世代代和几个世纪的过程中，它是由那些根本不相信这一切的人延续下来的。这就是我们所继承的东西。这让我们感到困难，因为我们的假设往往是唯物主义和基督教的。你知道，我们有一种文化覆盖层。我们很难回到希腊人自己的心态中去，很难回到索福克勒斯、欧里庇得斯时代，甚至更早的荷马时代。但我认为，如果不试图想象自己处于这样一个世界，你就无法真正理解希腊人
where the gods are the primary actors in the life of the various Greek cities and in the cosmos more generally, because it's only then that we can properly see how the Greeks saw themselves. Yeah. And that's the huge, I increasingly think that about the classical period of Greece and the centuries before it is that the challenges. to try and imagine yourself back into a world where you can escape the mythology and reenter a world of myth, to put it like that. Very nice. Very nice way to sum it up, Tom.
在这个世界里，神是各个希腊城邦以及更广泛的宇宙生活中主要行动者，因为只有这样，我们才能真正看到希腊人是如何看待自己的。是的。这是一个巨大的转变，我越来越这样认为，关于古希腊时期以及之前的几个世纪，挑战在于。试着想象自己回到这样一个世界，在那里你可以摆脱神话，重新进入一个神话的世界，可以这么说。非常好。汤姆，这是一个很好的总结。
But actually, an even better way would be for me to ask you, your favorite myth, top myth. My favorite myth was always the Odyssey. Really? Yeah, I always loved the Odyssey because it was my gateway drug. Yeah, okay, fair enough. And I would love to do an episode at some point on The Odyssey. We did one with Daniel Mandelson, but that's only for the club members, and club members can get it at the rest of history.com.
但实际上，更好的方式是我问你，你最喜欢的神话，最顶级的神话。我最喜欢的神话一直是《奥德赛》。真的吗？对，我一直很喜欢《奥德赛》，因为它是我的入门引导。好吧，有道理。我非常想找个时间做一期关于《奥德赛》的节目。我们和丹尼尔·曼德尔森做过一期，但那是专属于俱乐部会员的，俱乐部会员可以在therestishistory.com上收听。
But those who don't, maybe we could do one for the general listener. I think we should absolutely do one for the general listener. To give people an insight into the ruthless way in which we conduct our affairs, I think we should do that when Christopher Nolan's film at The Odyssey comes out. Yeah, let's do that. I think we should do a series that Restor's history subscribers will be able to hear first. That's a very good plan. Very good plan.
但对于没有加入的听众，也许我们可以为普通听众做一个。我觉得我们绝对应该为普通听众做一个。为了让大家了解我们处理事务的无情方式，我觉得我们应该在克里斯托弗·诺兰的《奥德赛》电影上映时做一期。好的，就这么办。我觉得我们应该做一个“历史其余部分”订阅者可以优先收听的系列节目。这是一个非常好的计划。非常好的计划。
Now you see the way. People get a little glimpse behind the curtain and they see the way in which we plan these things with no regard to commercial motives whatsoever. We're like the Olympians, aren't we? Yeah. Kind of drawing up rules and creatures of whim, but also of power. Dominic, before we go, you ask me my favorite Greek myth. That's yours. Theseus.
现在你看这种方式。人们窥见了幕后的一角，看到了我们策划这些事情时完全不考虑商业动机的样子。我们就像奥林匹斯山的神对吧？是的。有点像在制定规则，既是凭一时兴起行事的生物，又拥有强大的力量。多米尼克，在我们离开之前，你问了我最喜欢的希腊神话。你的呢？忒修斯。
Because that was my gateway. That was the first one I read, Thetius and the, and going at the labyrinth, fighting the minor tour and all that. I loved all that. The black sails. We can do one on Crete as well. Crete. Well, Crete, shawdy, is a series waiting to happen. It is.
因为那是我的入门神话。那是我读的第一本，忒修斯和，走进迷宫，与米诺陶洛斯战斗以及所有这些。我非常喜欢这些。黑色的风帆。我们也可以做一期关于克里特岛的节目。克里特岛。好吧，克里特岛，伙计，这是一个随时准备推出的系列节目。确实是的。
Right. It is basically the episode has turned into a scheduling meeting, which is lovely. We're back, aren't we, with an episode on someone who's very into the classics, namely Enoch Powell. Wow. That's a, that's a good segue. That's a thrilling transition, isn't it? And then after that, we've got a woman who is very into acting out the Greek myths, namely Emma Hamilton, who goes on to become Nelson's great paramour. And then after that, we have the return.
好了。基本上这期节目已经变成了一场排期会议，这很棒。我们回来了，对吧，这期节目关于一个非常热爱古典文化的人，也就是伊诺克·鲍威尔。哇。这是一个很好的过渡。这是一个令人兴奋的转折，对吧？然后在那之后，我们将迎来一位非常热衷于演绎希腊神话的女性，也就是埃玛·汉密尔顿，她后来成为了纳尔逊伟大的情人。然后在那之后，我们将迎来...
of the Admiral himself, Nelson. I can't wait. Cannot wait. Right, and that bumshall, thank you so much, Tom. That was absolutely fascinating, brilliant. A tour de force. We haven't had a tour de force for a while,
海军上将本人纳尔逊的回归。我等不及了。简直迫不及待。好了，谢谢你，汤姆。这真的太引人入胜、太精彩了。这是一场杰作。我们好久没有这么精彩的杰作了，
but now we've had a really good one. Brilliant. Thank you. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但现在我们有了一个非常棒的。太棒了。谢谢。再见。再见。这集节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。